Rem.
Give me a sec.
I didn't say anything else.
But just me, Rem.
Rem.
Me, Rem.
Me, me, me, Rem.
Rem,
Rem, Rem, Rem, Rem, Rem.
Me like Rem.
Rem, love.
Rem, Rem, Rem, Rem.
Rem.
I wonder what Donkey Bay is at that.
Like, what must be holiday?
Rem!
Rem is love.
Rem is life.
Rem is my purpose to live.
If I wake up and Rem is God.
Why even bother being alive?
Rem!
Give me a sec.
I actually did not set up for this stream at all.
Because of all my tabs.
I was just like, I gotta be on top for Rem.
Bro, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No, don't do this to me.
I, if I don't get Rem in my first game, I end stream.
I will end.
If no Rem, first game, me end stream.
me leave game and end stream i don't care how how many hours
i'm bad don't do it toky don't you won't be able to play for
a week me rem then i'll be free i'll be free no rem all lost
in the world Thank you.
Can't wait for game one.
And Toki doesn't get rem.
Don't say that.
I just that's all I want to do.
I was actually at the close of tabs.
I was not set up for the stream at all.
I was like lie in my bed zoning out for 30 minutes.
I was like, oh shit, it's 650.
I gotta get back on the PC.
Oh shit, new Space King.
Space King 5.
um she's rem so much she sounds like a car rem rem so i'm
just getting my rem on you know shortest stream ever all
right let's see i'm almost done closing all of these tabs
almost there 20 more tabs to go what's okay all right 20
more tabs to go give me a sec i'm still closing tabs right
now i i open these be like i'll look at them later and it
hasn't been later yet by the way i have a negative uh i
think i have like a 20 win rate on rem um let me check
actually let's see what my update stats are on oh 32 it went
up guys i have a 32 win rate on rem of 22 games guys guys
doesn't matter that i'm i i don't that I'm losing.
I get to be rem.
I don't care if I'm bad at him.
I get to play rem.
I don't care.
I am.
Um, um, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for space king.
Um, uh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Papa smirk.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I remember that new she feeling.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I have two questions for you, Doki.
Do you think Deadlock Lobbies have more insane chat messages
than other games?
And thoughts on Mr. Dorman.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I honestly have not played, okay, other than one time that
the guy put me in his alt and I was crying because I didn't
know how to parkour.
Because it was the first time I was in a Dormat alt.
And then I was playing with Surefer, Gully, Ben, and Hune.
I was just like, ah, they're like, just do popcorns, like,
ah,
I'm actually, surprisingly, I'm not gone against a lot of,
uh, I'm surprisingly not gone against a lot of Mr. Dorman,
um, but, but Mo and Krill, though, Mo, I think he's on a
list somewhere, I, but Mo and Krill and Drifter, they're
definitely on a list somewhere, I won't say what list, but,
but it's one of those what
anyway let me finish closing my tabs uh real quick guys I'm
almost done closing off I debated about what to stream today
because I'm so sorry that the schedule was late and then a
surprise deadlock stream but I've been playing deadlock
non-stop for the last four days now um i still hate the game
like but i do it for rem but i don't hate rem my love for
rem transcends my absolute hatred for mobas my we're doing
it vanilla style by the way there's no mods on it i had
debated if i wanted to install mods because i feel like i
know like everyone's saying like um playing with mods is the
deadlock experience but like i need to get like out this
game first before i mod the game like i barely i don't know
what i don't know what's going on like yeah it's like i hate
deadlock plays four days i think i've accumulated 20 plus
hours i'll show you guys i know for sure i have like at
least 20 plus hours of deadlock alone um and we have sound
guy here um drifter victor and moan krill they're on a list
somewhere they they might have traveled together to some
undisclosed destination of uh of an island somewhere in the
ocean uh i have i may or may not have been touched by some
of them allegedly allegedly i would also like to say that
i'm perfectly content with my life and uh i will not do
anything with it
Um, very bread.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Considering Drifter is only participating in the ritual to
hunt peeps, he's definitely only on multiple lists.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Uh, let me show you guys.
Um, how many hours of deadlock I've played?
Uh, ram!
later live on stream maybe i'll download the infamous
remlock mod because right now i i don't know what i'm doing
i i don't know what's going on all right let me show you
guys look okay uh rem 12 okay don't these are like done
honestly the rem stuff was done in the last four days uh the
show was on The Rem Blushing.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Endless there, super chat.
I feel like I'm going to be so confused.
But we'll do it.
We'll do it live on stream.
We'll download Remlock live on stream just to experience
that with you guys.
Joki won 18 corners a drift.
And he rushes her screaming.
Gambit never folds.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Rem.
Oh my god.
I've had rem as a bonus split.
Guys, do not.
Guys, I don't look at my denies.
The fact that seven, I had less games on seven and I have
like a million more denies.
I had 230 denies on seven and the 25 on rem.
Guys, I don't care.
I because I'm not that old care I I'm just from 2 30 to 25 I
I hate laning so I hate I hate the lane phase so much I I
have boy on April that's actually crazy I didn't even really
Unless it was that bad.
I'm just here to steal sinners.
Okay.
I just hate laying, guys.
Lolly, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Nice to remember.
Think of all the Space King episode 4 of the Misses.
That should be the one, really long fourth level of the
Trader Detector Simulation.
from the start of the episode.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I played Deadlock for Rem and for Rem alone.
That's all I can.
Ram.
I actually didn't realize this was that bad.
Okay.
How many hours do I even have on Rem?
Let me check, actually.
Deadlock.
How many hours do i have on this character i let's see rem
oh shit i just typed in rem on the tracker versus my own
name i am rem i am rem kirk let's see i have does this tell
me how many hours i played on this character i just know
okay wait it doesn't even tell me what is it What is my...
I actually have a 50% win rate on 7.
The one Ivy game.
Yeah, the one Ivy game.
Because I couldn't get Remmed.
Thank God someone left.
Oh yeah, this is my match history.
It's like Rem, Rem, Rem, Rem, Rem, Rem, Rem, Rem, Rem, Rem,
Rem, Rem.
Rem, Rem, Rem, Rem.
Ram!
I have such, I win all my, do I win, but Jerry?
Not only Ram!
I'm the only red.
There's enough greens.
But there's like...
All in.
I'm all in.
I don't even know how many hours I have on him.
It doesn't even tell me.
Does it...
Wait, if I click on Heroes, does it show me how many hours I
have on this character?
20 I have played 22 wait is 22 games I just want to know how
many hours I fucking logged into this game the last four
days I just want to know guys I think rem is her main guys
you guys know how where I could check how many hours I've
infested in deadlock of just playing rem i i can't tell i no
way because he's so look at him he's so cute look at this
little guy rem i like my pillow i like rem uh 30 hours at
least 30 i played in 40 days by the way i picked up deadlock
four days ago he is he's just a little guy don't you
definitely remember the 21st night do you remember the 21st
night of September thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you but I don't I don't remember anything about this
even I played this a year plus ago you guys have to remember
a year plus ago was very very very different a lot of things
has changed a year plus ago um and so i was basically
relearning from scratch for i think i'm doing pretty well
okay guys look i'll show you guys look this was my very
first game on rem let me show you this was um my wait where
was it Okay, wait, no, I need to show you guys this 5k
damage one that one.
Okay
This is my 4.6k my on my first day one, by the way, this is
day one of rem It's like day one of playing a we won Wait,
we lost, never mind.
We lost, dude.
I was in the game.
I was around.
By the way, the game was really, really hard because Shure4
was playing with us.
So obviously the MMR, as you can tell which one's Shure4.
You can, so like, I was literally a baby, chucked into,
like, the deep end of, like, I was just born.
And it threw me into the pool.
be like good luck dokey i yeah that's yeah they're like
because like because like apparently the matches in standard
in standard goes to like whoever has the highest average in
your group so it was like good luck swim or sink yeah sink
or swim so it was it was like my it was the my my one of my
My first day, by the way.
My first day playing Deadlock again.
I don't remember anything about Deadlock, by the way.
And then, from there, I've crawled.
I've learned to crawl.
I've learned to walk.
I've learned to run.
And from there, bam!
34k depth!
I've learned I learned to walk I've learned to jog I've
learned to run 34k damage I'm growing I went from newborn
baby to toddler I in four days my that's who's last you see
who's last and not me i've seen enough put her in eternity's
love that's fucking right the coughing baby is now a
coughing toddler like
yes and then look at this oh we lost but look at it was wait
is this the one look at it oh wait no not this one uh look
at wait was it this one i know i lost it when i okay look at
look at this oh we lost but guess who was the key player
that's right i am the key player right with my five hole
kill it's all about the this baby.
Hey, I'm on support.
I'm on support.
It doesn't matter.
Not my fault.
I'm the key player, so it's not my fault.
In four days, I've learned to crawl.
I've learned to stand up for myself.
So anyway, I debated for a long time about whether or not to
stream Deadlock, because I I am really bad at this game.
For those who don't know, I never learned MOBA games at all.
I didn't grow up with MOBA games.
I found the MOBA aspect of any game.
Doesn't matter what MOBA I'm playing.
Really, really, really boring.
I hate farming.
I hate laning.
As you guys can see, I really hate denying stuff.
I hate, I hate...
Every aspect of what it means to play a MOBA game.
I hate reading the items and at the learn all the items and
then all the counters.
Me left to right.
Me don't care.
You know what I do?
I do cube build.
I stand next to the shop and go, boop, boop, boop.
And then I go.
If that's how I click Q build and then shop And then maybe
if I'm feeling a little spicy I buy a knockdown and or or
even a disarming hex Whoa If I'm feeling a little spicy
yeah yeah she's a little frisky anyway uh what else what
else i want to tell you guys about my about rem uh but yes i
barely was super chat thinking thank you i debated a long
time about what about if i should stream deadlock because i
was because like um i didn't know if i want to show you guys
how bad i am at this game just because i i never grew up
with moba so i'm so i don't know when i don't know when to
rotate i don't know when it's a good time to get boxes yet i
don't know like when i can do my little tunnels or like farm
camps i i'm always so confused and then i'm like i hate i'm
whole leaning so bad but when i was like do i show the world
do i show my dragons that i'm not a prodigy or amazing at
every shooter game I play.
I'm so, and I was like, no.
Do I let them know the harsh reality that I'm not perfect?
I don't know.
I'm sorry.
You have to find out this way, guys.
I'm so sorry.
I know.
I have to be bad.
I know, guys.
I'm sorry.
I have to show you guys that I can bleed, that I can be bad
at a I It's cuz there's but Doki you're a gamer.
I know, but it's the MOBA part the MOBA part is like the
wall Like I'm trying I'm smashing my head against the wall,
but they've like reinforced it with titanium and I'm like
I'm still Smashing it, but it's not coming down.
I don't know why I feel they're like people are like Doki
You should start reading the I was like I don't know why
it's not working that's stupid I I don't know what else to
do I how do I play this game reading that's crazy I'll
fucking give me real solutions here give me give me real
ideas real solutions give me a left to right build i know
but i decided today will be the day i'll i stream deadlock
so because actually i was sort of wanting to play dead i was
like do i do i play deadlock or do i stream today and i was
just like wait a minute i can do both i know wait i can do
both i can stream deadlock i can play deadlock and and
stream it oh my god wait a minute a revolutionary idea guys
um so i decided i was just like so i'm really sorry guys i i
think i like at one point like i think it was like two days
ago i played deadlock from um 11 p.m.
Wait, no, 10 p.m.
Till 8 a.m.
No, 10 p.m.
Till 10 a.m.
Two days ago, because I was like, I wanted, I just wanted
more, I just want to get better at Ram.
I just want to figure out Ram, and I love him so much.
He's just a little guy.
I'm Ram.
He's just, he's just a little guy, and I just, I just want
to be good at this little guy because he's so cute.
And, like, he throws his pillow.
Oh, yeah, re-binding everything.
He throws his pillows and he's done his little minions.
And then he goes nap time.
And he does that.
And then he's like, oh, he's such a cute little guy.
He's just a little chud with his little chudlings.
And I love him.
He's so cute.
And he's like, me.
And look at this.
Okay, this is my favorite part of a rem.
He's like, hi, hi, I'm rem.
And he's like, I'm rem.
But shorter.
Come on, come on, play with me.
He's like, look at him!
Look at him!
He's like, mew, mew, mew.
He's like, mew!
Look at him, he's such a little gremlin too.
He's like, look at him.
He's such a, oh my God, he is round, but he's shorter.
Oh!
He's like my little, my little chuddling.
My little chud.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, look at him.
Go, he's just so cute.
Omni, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, bring the game down.
Don't worry, I got you.
I got you.
All right, let me know if it's better.
I'll do the...
I'll do...
Oh, wait.
Let me do the cool down real fast.
Is it this button?
All right.
Let me know if the cool...
Nine, nine, nine, nine.
All right, and then...
And then I call this friendship.
I know this is called tagline, but I was like, guys i have
friendship friendship is magic i call i call this one
friendship even though i know it's tagline um and uh also uh
what is that oh yeah so i've been playing with like sure for
in them um and uh like almost every night is i sure for uh
or madara and i've recently convinced gomez to Please,
that's so, I just wanted more people to play with.
So, like, I would just be like, if this person's not
available, I go to, guys, guys, REM, REM, you want REM?
I'd be sorry, me want REM.
You want Deadlock, me REM, REM, REM, REM, REM, REM.
So I'm trying, I'm slowly getting more people to play
Deadlock with me so I can keep playing REM.
Because the more people you're playing with, the higher your
chances are, you get to play REM.
The higher, the chances I get.
Rem, guys, you don't understand.
I need any pause, any of raise the percentages because then
I make everyone else play every other character and then
they play Rem on.
So this is the strat, guys.
I'll show you the strat, the rem strat.
here it is.
So when you're playing, I was playing soloing at first, but
then I think like Goodmas might join us later.
And I was like, oh, that's cool.
That I can guarantee Rem.
Anyway, so this is the strat, guys.
This is what I do I go to standard and then I high prior rem
okay this was yeah and then my lowest prior would be whoever
uh actually let me down it a bit more my lowest prior will
be whoever I'm playing with and it's their main and then and
then I'll be a second because I'm trying to figure out what
to put as like my throwaway character uh so so because if
you're playing with a group so if I if I'm playing with
Groo.
I'm playing with Sure4Gully, Ben and Hune.
We put everybody else would put Rem as lowest priority for
me and then I would guarantee Rem because the game would be
like, oh well we have to make sure everybody gets the
character they want.
So I get Rem!
And obviously sometimes it doesn't work 100% time, but as
you guys can see from my profile as you guys can see from my
match history, Rem, Rem, Rem, Rem, Rem, Rem, Rem, Rem, Rem,
Rem rem rem it's work it's been working rem rem rem rem rem
rem rem rem rem rem rem rem rem rem Ram and then there you
go I will you fully the rent I this is day four I'm only on
you don't understand the biggest issue the thing about
playing in a group is that it doesn't average your it
doesn't towards whoever is the best player in your on your
group the stack you're in and i'm playing with sure for it
and he's really really good at dead and madara i think it
got you was eternus before rank reset so i'm there i'm
literally like i go in i was like guys everyone's denying me
right now
I'd be like, I'd be like, guys, like, guys, everyone, I'm
sorry.
They're all so, they're all denying my arms.
Yeah, yeah, so, but I stuck out of it.
I think it's, I think it helped me improve really, really
fast.
Oh, yeah, and then I was stealing my team's sinners.
And then Sheriff always, I was like, what are you doing?
I was like, I just, I just, he's doing cities like no the
enemy team not ours i got yelled at a lot on on day one yes
and you'll be like stop yelling at her she's she's new at
the game she's learning and he's like i'm not protecting you
i'm gonna leave you to die and i'm like no no please please
i'll stop i'll stop
He's like, I'm never saving your life again.
I was like, no, I stopped.
Fane is a good teacher.
I'm just, I'm just a, I'm just a little guy.
Five plus Smurf, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
of being good i said don't guys i'm gonna i'm gonna make it
guys i'm gonna show you all i'm gonna be oracle rem i'll
show most likely i'll be hard stuck bronze but but a little
chud can dream a little chud can dream i'll show you all
i'll be the strongest bronze one rem out there
You'll see!
You'll all see!
Dream for the stars, little rem.
Don't worry.
People are like, do I know?
I know.
On the first day I was showing this on the first day.
Look at this.
Right here.
My little...
My little hideout.
Where I cry to myself every...
Where I cry to myself when I don't get to play rem.
Why won't they let me be Rem?
When I grow up, I want to be just like you.
You're only Rem.
Am I crying, Queenie?
I'd be like, today, today, today a drifter, a drifter
touched me.
I shouldn't say that.
I shouldn't say I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, I'm playing too much Deadlock, guys.
I'm, you don't, I've been, I'm sorry, I've been playing too
much Deadlock.
I shouldn't say that.
I'm thinking, I will say, Deadlock VC and Mad Chat gets
absolutely wild.
I can, I'm sorry, I'm so sorry, I've been corrupted by
Deadlock Chatters.
I'm so sorry.
Stop, Jesus.
guys i i will say deadlock players are no filter they have
absolutely no filter i learned a lot in my deadlock
playthroughs guys i i learned a lot
do not repeat what you see in all chat there is oh speaking
of voice chat the ic league is um is moving like we all know
that league is planning on introducing voice chat but yeah i
see that they are already introducing like the concepts of
like what's gonna be the voice chat and stuff like that
there's gonna be voice changes added to league voice chat
and you have to have like a honors you have to have like
what was it like a honor system to be able to activate
league the league vc i just thought it was funny that they
added voice changes to like i get it's really like the
female players but You know people are going to abuse the
shit out of that.
People are going to abuse the absolute.
And I feel like, especially when you're laning, it's going
to be so chaotic during laning phase.
Because you hear everybody.
You see your bottom, mid, and top lane.
And jungler all talking to each other.
And you're just like, I just, I don't care what's going on
between my support and their duo.
I don't care.
So it's gonna, I feel like it's gonna be fucking crazy.
Anyway, I'm Rem.
Yay!
I'm Rem, Rem, Rem, Rem.
I know Rem.
Oh yeah, I was supposed to play Project Zomboid yesterday,
and also today.
But then I got distracted by Deadlock.
I,
um, Trippin invited me to the big, uh, roleplay server that
he set up for Project Zomboid.
I might join later, maybe after this stream.
I don't know.
But Strippen said he'll teach me a bit.
And he said I can be a police officer.
Because I was like, oh, I don't know how to play this.
I don't really know how to play Project Zomboid.
I never really done.
I'm also not really, really good at RP.
But he said if he'll make me a police officer.
And he'll like teach me the game too.
Whenever I'm free.
Mr. Broken Bond.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I got distracted.
by rem i really did i i wake up i eat food i rem i think
yesterday yesterday i played deadlock um i mean you can sort
of tell you can see from here what time did i play deadlock
yesterday i started 18 30 31st where is it right
here oh yeah here this is the two days ago.
I was like, whoa, it's still the 8th, it's still the 31st?
Like, here you go.
Started here at midnight.
31st midnight.
And then all the way till 1103.
And then I slept.
And then I woke up.
And then I played all the way till here.
I don't care.
that my win rate is 30%.
Guys, I get to be REM.
And that's all that matters.
Yippee!
Yippee, yippee.
REM, REM, REM.
REM.
Naps are fun.
Exactly.
30% isn't zero, guys.
Guys, you gotta remember.
I was chucked in.
I was just born and then they threw me into the ocean.
I sink or swim.
I had to figure it out in high low lobbies.
Like right off me getting wins is a miracle.
To be fair, um, Sherpa was like try, like, well he wasn't
like trying super duper hard, but he was clawing his way to
victory for us.
Like, like he, he tried.
He, he made sure we win he made it was a baby turtle
situation i want to try and find the one where like he had
like a crazy uh calico build that literally made three
people rage quit i think it was this one which one was it
where um he had a crazy calico build and he was like here
this one he did
It was this, it was this compared to all of us.
Basically, by the end of it, like, three people literally
rage quit at the end.
Like, and was like, like, just did not want to deal with it.
Fucking gun, Gallico.
I don't know.
I don't know what the fuck he was doing, but apparently it
was very OP.
Yeah, we were lagging.
Like when he, every time he shoots his gun, we were lagging.
Yeah, apparently when he shot his gun at someone, people
were like, I can't see.
Like the energy was just like, I can't see.
Apparently there was like, all of us were just frame
dropping.
We looked at his gun.
Wait, let me see if I can look at the replay.
I'm downloading.
It was actually wild.
Light gun is the ultimate weapon.
It's because you had like stacks or something.
So the thing about this game, what I've learned is that
there's like an items where you can buy where you get a
kill.
It built like you can stack your damage or some shit or like
your stats.
You can stack your stats every kill you get and it's
unlimited.
So like there's no, it's like, I was like, they're like, oh
yeah, they get like one time I got like killed by like the
great, sorry, I'm trying not to say his other name.
Grey Talon.
Sorry.
Some people call him Gay Talon.
But, so, every time Grey Talon alts and the Burt, his alt
hits you, he gets an increase of damage.
And then same with Drifter.
Every time he gets a solo kill, his damage increases.
So, there's some characters that do that.
Or, like, you have to buy an item.
that lets you increase your stats.
And I was like, oh, is there a limit?
And then they were like, oh, you sweet summer child.
There's no limit.
It's unlimited.
And I was like, oh.
Oh.
I was just like, oh.
And at one point, I don't remember which team we were
against.
I think like, I think like the enemy team was all, I think
like, rumors or some shit.
And then they were like, Doki, never go out there alone.
Like, you, you, you will die.
They like, before the game started, they looked at the enemy
team.
And they're like, to me, he's like, Doki, find yourself a
buddy.
Whatever you go, do not lean by yourself, Doki, or you will
die.
They're like, do not get caught out by yourself against this
team, not survive and I was like really but but what about
the sinners and they're like do not get the sinners do this
is the one game where you do not go up by yourself they're
like they're like this is the one game you are you cannot be
alone dokey always have a buddy with you and I'm like but
what about but the sinners no no do not get the sinners
dokey do not do not the outside past curfew and I was just
like okay okay yes you'll protect me and then they caught
yeah they caught me it's like save the lapu-poo and I was
like I'm saved the lapu-poo save me yeah I need adult
supervision they're like how did our lapu-poo die I was like
I just left alone a child is not safe in this lobby it's
been a while four days guys it really has been a wild four
days all right let me show you the gun calico oh my god
already forgot which game it was was this one yeah watch
replay i've never been in a replay system before by the way
uh mr love get down i think it was here oh my god oh my god
guys it's loading in right now out okay where is it oh by
the way she's not supposed to kill mid boss that fast
he's he was not supposed to kill kill it that what the fuck
oh jesus So totally...
The faster you die, the faster it goes away.
Like...
When she got split shot, my FPS was just tanking.
Ah, yes.
God look cool.
It's actually crazy.
Three guys rage quit, by the way, at the end.
It was...
Yeah, it was an actual turret.
It was insane.
Like, people...
They just don't live.
Like...
Holy shit!
What the fuck?
That's not...
The sweet and merciful chest.
Suppressing fire!
I would...
Yeah, so...
And then, the thing is, I was still learning, and then
they're like, Oh, wow, that's so scummy, pocket gun looko.
And then he was just like, a Rem was never even healed me.
And I'm like, I did.
I healed you that one time.
I was like, not true.
Not true.
I healed Adelie's.
Holy shit.
And he was gone.
I think, yeah, I'm going to just leave.
This guy's gone.
But this guy is...
Yeah, if it gets fed and he was getting...
Really, really fed.
Oh, second guy gone.
And then third guy gone.
60k, dude.
So...
Yeah, this guy can shoot.
And then three...
Four... Fourth guy gone.
Let's see if they're prepared for this.
It was just over.
Oh, no, like, oh my god.
Sorry, let me find the big fight.
Is it this one?
Oh my god.
Frame is catching up.
It's catching up.
I'm trying to find, like, the one big fight where, like, he
just killed everybody.
They were, everybody was just, gosh.
Was this one?
Oh, you shit!
I could kill him.
This is my POV.
This is me wild.
Wee!
I'm so lost.
I don't know where I'm going.
Where am I going?
Yay!
I'm just a little guy.
I don't know where I'm going.
I'm happy, happy, happy.
Watch it up.
Yippee!
Where am I shooting?
I don't know.
I'm rude.
Look, I'm just...
Oh, I was like, we're so sinner.
Oh, there it is.
Wrong hole.
I found it, guys.
I found the sinner.
I know.
Yay!
Where do I go, guys?
I'm so...
Welcome to the Age of Chemical!
Yippee!
Thank you!
Yeah!
I'm so lost!
Oh, is this a fight?
Oh, I don't hope that doesn't touch me!
I-
Don't worry, guys!
I'm helping!
Am I helping?
I shot him, guys!
I shot him!
I- I- There you go.
Hey guys!
Oh, she's so far.
My gun doesn't do the damage.
I...
Nice one.
Plus 30 damage.
I shot him.
Oh, and I got fucked there.
I was like, guys, where are my friends?
Help!
Help them at Boom Boom!
Yay!
Thank you!
and I was like, my hero, my hero.
Anyway, I'm going back in with 600 HP.
I didn't learn my lesson.
And he switched back for a second.
And then he's like, and then he's here doing this.
And then here's me be like, guys, how do I get to mid boss?
Guys, I'm here.
I made it to mid boss.
I'm here, I hope, I helped everyone, I'm here, I'm here, I'm
here, and then, and then I'm just, where's the, guys, I'm
gonna grab sinners, guys, yay, I'm here, and I hope, guys,
guys, I grabbed did it and I'm gonna grab this center and
then everybody's fighting and I'm like everyone and then and
then they're all having a fucking war I'm like guys guys I'm
almost here I'm almost here everyone don't worry I'm here I
made
it everyone I made it I'm here now I sweat I said I die
and then i died guys guys i took a rejuve i did it everyone
i took a rejuve
so um that's i participated that was day two that's a day
two though guys that was day two of rem now we're on day
five day five of room we got those guys yeah I pressed for
everyone everyone I pressed for and they're sleeping they're
sleeping yeah in fact in fact let me show you day four I
don't you don't know if I did anything on day four I yeah I
know the map 5% more
I know the map.
The tunnels, I still get lost in the tunnels.
I don't know where, like, my tiny tunnels are sometimes.
I always go one route.
One route for the tunnels, and it's where the shop is,
because that's the only place I remember where the tunnels
are actually.
But I don't know where the other tunnels are.
I gain 5% more map knowledge within those five days of
playing.
And let me get some water real quick.
I'll be right back.
Back.
I'm also a ground rem i do not know how to not know how to
jump very well on i don't know how to do the movement stuff
very well i'm still a ground rem by the way i don't know how
to like do like the parkour shit that everyone does uh alan
stuff sick solid thank you with super chat thank you thank
you all right where am i uh where is me where's rem is that
me there's me all right i don't know if i thing that's the
thing i oh where's me yippee don't worry guys i am still
confused i was like guys don't worry i'm coming over to help
i'm look at that kill secured i did my part I Look at that
kill has been secured We did it Look at that kill absolutely
secured Look at that Oh, not and filled and filled the
pocket kill secured Wait, I'm like Guys, I did it.
I helped.
I unfilled the pocket.
Out of all the characters, I could have used that on.
I used it on the pocket.
Look at that.
Don't thank me, guys.
Thank Rim.
Oh, bring the sound effects.
No problem.
I got you.
Let's see.
I believe it'll be gameplay audio, right?
I'll turn it down to...
90 or 85.
Let me go.
Just trying to figure out the world.
Let me throw that...
Ooh, that one minion.
Oh, I sure got him.
I sure got that one minion.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
I sure did it.
Don't worry.
guys i'm pushing the lane everybody oh don't worry oh and
then there's the big fight don't worry rem is coming uh
rem's coming over to help whoa whoa give me a sec got the
boxes give me a sec nope rem's coming all right rem doesn't
know what she's doing but rem's here oh it is
don't worry guys i got our sinners our side sinners whoa
look at that wave clear you're welcome no need to thank me
i'm a hero uh oh another wave clear don't worry i did it
guys i got mid lane don't i'm here oh my god when is there
an actual fight i think this is where we have a big fight
right here.
It's just me laning the entire time.
I just been in mid lane the entire time.
I just, don't worry guys.
Rem's still in mid lane.
Do not worry.
I still did my job.
Still here.
In mid lane.
Oh my god.
The walking game.
Wait, don't worry, I'm here.
I shall now proceed to assist my team.
Watch this out.
Peak gameplay.
Don't worry, I used the knockdown when everybody got hit.
Don't worry, I slept one guy.
I could have used my knockdown to Terry.
I'm helping!
I'm...
Yamato's getting touched, but I'm helping.
I...
That's bad.
Whoa!
Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
Look at that.
And then... I was like, oh shit, that thing was gonna
explode.
Watch it and BAM!
I shall now proceed to help.
I'm so talented.
Thank you.
Watch this.
Now I help kill the thing.
There you go.
And that's how you do it.
That's how you do it, guys.
Day four of REM.
Now.
Now it's day five.
after I had to give you guys a step-by-step commentary on
how how it's been the one hour step-by-step commentary of
what four days of deadlock has been like for me all right so
80 day five of learning rem guys give it up for day five of
learning rem
you're gonna i know the experienced deadlock players you're
gonna be like why is she doing this why are you doing that
why did you buy that item why guys guys guys i've accepted
it i i am bad at deadlock i've i've accepted it guys i've
i've i've lived with this i thought in my head i've
Living it right now, I know, I know, I don't know what I'm
doing.
I, I just cue build and I let my, let my build take me to
where it takes me.
I, but despite all of that, despite being bad at the
deadlock, despite being bad at this game, despite not
reading, every, it's all all right because I'm Rem.
I'm Rem.
Despite it all.
Despite having a 30% win rate on Rem.
I still love Rem.
Rem cute.
That's all.
I'm just a little chud.
And that's okay.
I've accepted that.
I am just a little chud with my little chudlings.
And that's okay, guys.
It's okay to be bad at this one game.
It's okay.
I can be amazing.
I can be great at all these other games.
And it's okay to be bad at just one game.
Only the one game I'm bad at is Deadlock.
The only one.
And it's okay.
It's...
It's all right.
I only have one game I'm not good at, guys.
And it's okay to be...
Yeah.
Just that one, honestly.
Only one.
All right.
Let's see.
I think...
Are they...
all right let's let's add we're gonna play deadlock it's
funny how the only game you were bad is the one that
requires reading comprehension thank you for the super chat
gordon thank you thank you you see i could play an easier
character where i could actually be like brain empty just
shoot gun but but it's not rem it's not him that's the thing
it's not rem i don't care It's not him.
Doesn't matter.
I'm only here.
For Bram.
I did.
I did go to a secret room.
Let's see.
We can go from here.
I'm pretty sure.
It's like.
Yeah.
My little room.
My little crying corner.
When the enemy team has Moe and Cradle Drifter.
and Victor.
I go over here and go
He tripped it on me
My little crying critter
It's okay And it's okay It's okay guys Oh yeah I didn't even
start the queue Give me a sec Let me Let me Let me start the
queue real quick.
Alright, it's this way.
Average reaction.
Alright.
Let me start the queue.
I tried streetball.
I was not, like, a huge fan of it.
Not gonna lie.
I didn't like streetball that much.
It was just too... I don't know.
It felt really boring to me.
In my little room.
I better get REM.
Oh, I better get REM.
I'll be so sad after everything I said about REM and I don't
get REM on my first game.
I will be very, very sad.
Oh, I'm going to be very, very sad in my first game.
I do not even get REM.
Come on, come on, come on, ram, ram, ram, ram!
Yes!
Ram!
Ram, ram, ram, ram, ram, ram, ram, ram, ram, ram, ram, ram,
ram, I get to be a ram.
Ram!
Yeah!
RIM!
Half the battle is over.
Yeah!
RIM!
Yes, I think she likes RIM.
Is it?
Swap.
Yeah!
RIM RIM!
RIM!
Um, oh shit, wait, I need like, okay, what I do, because I
keep forgetting how to do build, is I take a snapshot of the
ability point order, and I put it next to me, because I
always forget what my point order is.
I always forget, like, what to upgrade first, even after
four days, it's still not ingrained in my head, it's
still...
There's no need to be said.
What do you mean, my friend?
After four days, I still don't know what to upgrade.
Wait.
RIM RIM.
RIM.
Rem, rem, rem.
Rem.
Ooh, item, item, item.
Item, item.
Yay!
That's not me!
I didn't lose that soul!
Rem, rem, rem.
I'm just a little guy.
I'm helping.
I see, hey, bro.
Ram, ram, ram.
Oh, I couldn't confirm it.
I was reloading.
Wait, wait, wait.
He's so low.
I'm helpful.
Don't worry.
I'm going to start helping now.
Wait, what?
I pressed no!
I messed up.
It wasn't even supposed to be that.
Oh well.
Rem.
Don't worry.
I was supposed to grab pillow first but I fucked up.
I could have pillowed her.
Rem, rem,
rem.
You think he knows I'm here?
Oh shit.
You know what?
Just for fun.
have to get whoa no
all right it should open up below
whoa wait where's my friend why did he oh item item item
i know but i don't do it
Pillow!
No pillow!
It's okay.
It'll be fine.
I believe.
No, I have to re- no!
Pillow time.
Pillow!
Get him!
It's fine.
I have pillow.
All right.
Friend, where?
Oh my god!
Friend.
It's okay.
Everything is fine.
Hello!
Oh, I missed hello.
I missed the hello, though.
Thank you.
Great action, Lord.
Let's see.
Item.
Item time.
Oh my god, but he's going in.
It's fucking wild.
Rem, rem,
rem.
Rem, rem, rem.
He's one.
I did this thing.
Yay!
Oh, boxes.
for that guys I'm doing the thing
oh it's so close to sinners time it's almost sinners time oh
I cannot wait oh sending is gonna be so fun oh oh god I'm
okay we're five
that's right stay away oh shit wait Oh, stop, stop, stop,
stop, stop, stop, don't, don't, don't.
Don't let him do that!
Why do we let him do that?
Guys, are we losing our lane?
Because I can't tell.
I...
Here we go.
That's nice.
Oh my god.
He's so low.
He's actually one.
Please hit him!
Oh, I love hide and seek.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he was actually what?
Oh, I hope he lives.
Helpful.
Yes!
Rem, rem, rem!
I'm like, Yes!
I might have missed the pillow, but I won the war.
I...
Box, box, box time.
Box, box.
Box, box, box.
Box.
I love my boxes.
Box time.
Where do I go?
I'm lost.
I'm just a Pokemon now.
I'm running.
I'm okay.
Um, let's see.
I like my pillow.
And it's this, and then, um, this.
Where am I helping?
Ah, they're gonna take out me now!
I just got friendship, I'm sorry!
Get out of here!
I wanna go and do this stuff!
I need to go to my sinners!
No!
My sinners!
They're taking it!
Thank you!
I start sinning like a- No!
No!
My sinners!
Let's take out Abrams.
Ah!
I'm okay.
He took our sinners.
My money!
See, it's like my fear.
Fear taking me.
Oh god, there he is.
Get him, get him, get him.
Ah!
So low though.
There we go.
Oh my god, they mean to fucking get out!
Where did he go?
Oh, you see?
I hope...
I helped.
Alright.
You don't...
You can imagine, what if that worked though?
Imagine that actually working.
Yay.
It was a zoning, exactly.
It was a zoning alert.
Exactly, guys.
I'm helping.
I am providing assistance.
What do I do next?
Okay, I need to do five here.
Wait, wait, I can do a ton.
No, I have to be in my lane by myself!
Haha, get hit!
don't worry
get away from me
now I have trophy collector see guys I can oh my god oh my
god get away I'm a little guy get
away from me get away you're not five oh my god thank God
okay All right, we're fine.
We're fine You think I should help I should help I should
help don't worry.
I'm here
Yeah REM REM
Yeah Now I stay here Whoop
That's me.
Now I can roam.
Yippee.
Alright, let me walk around.
This is the only one thing I know how to do.
Now I can...
I won my area now.
Oh, Riff's here.
Don't worry, Rimm's coming.
To enter Lash's world.
Oh, shit.
Wait, they have a Lash.
Don't worry, I'm here.
I assisted.
With my presence, I don't know what I did, but I assisted.
Plus one movement speed.
Wait, but I got, oh wait.
Just center, center, center, center, center, center.
Rum, rum, rum, rum, rum, rum.
Ah!
Don't be a jerk.
Sure.
I take those.
I...
Oh, I didn't get it!
We, I, we got it!
I know.
You scared of me, Rem!
I don't know why, but that's fine.
You scared of the child!
Oh, I have to go with blue.
Blue, blue, blue.
Blue, blue.
What if I farm farm farm farm wait, they got it wait.
Wait, they got it.
I can go in my guys guys Look at this.
This is my tunnel.
This is the only pathway.
I know I go here And then I go down here.
This is the only path.
I know as rem I don't know how to go anywhere else.
Oh shit.
Everybody's fighting, but like I'll come over soon Oh my
god, where's the door?
Door door door Don't worry.
I'm here I got lost
Oh shit There you go Sorry I get overwhelmed when you guys
are watching me I get nervous
Guys because you guys are watching me so I got nervous I
thought you knew the way It's because you guys are watching
so I got very nervous I got performance anxiety.
I got performance anxiety, yes.
It's understandable.
I do a lot.
I got performance anxiety.
It's, it's, it happens.
It happens, guys.
She forgot the only route she knows.
I don't know.
I should actually...
Knock.
Knock down.
There you go.
Did I buy it?
No, I didn't.
Oh, that's what my team does.
I do not.
It's over.
I will strike them down.
Who's reborn?
Good job.
I help, I help, I help.
I help, I help.
I'm Rem, Rem.
Don't worry.
What you mean?
Oh, don't worry.
Our animals got...
Don't worry.
Got you!
And I got you!
And I stopped guiding.
Wait, I could sleep.
I could sleep.
What am I doing?
Look at how sleepable they're all.
Oh my god, they're so sleepable, guys.
They're so sleepable!
They were asking for me to sleep them.
Pillow, pillow, pillow, pillow.
I can steal, I can steal, I can steal.
I can steal that Abram's not gonna save.
I'll steal my own.
I can still.
My
There you go, that's fine.
Coming over.
Okay.
I can steal.
I can steal this.
Anyone's in there.
Someone's in there.
They were waiting for me.
I heard it.
They do have to sing.
I did it.
Guys, I think they were...
Oh, there's my team.
Man.
Oh, I love it.
Oh, yeah, I've upgrades.
Look at me again.
Bye.
Oh, shit.
Everything saved by...
Please save me.
No!
It's over here.
Everything's fine.
Okay, it's okay.
Oh, that was scary.
At least they came back.
What a hero.
Oh god, okay.
I can get something really cool now.
Thank you, Ram.
Oh, I can find knockdown out.
Oh, by knockdown.
Overreact for nothing.
I did!
I'm literally a kill-ass cannon!
I'm surprised I can't even walk without getting a heart
attack.
I'm right in life.
At this rate...
It is, it's crazy that I'm allowed to like go out without
adult supervision right now.
Oh, there is an Abrams right there.
I will surround.
Oh, I can steal that.
I can steal that over there.
I can steal it.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
I can go help our graves.
I'll steal that.
after I helped my graves.
Don't worry, I got you graves.
I'm here.
Don't worry.
I can steal that.
Yeah, you can pause.
Okay, and then.
Oh, shit.
Wait, but I...
No, I just wanted to steal that.
But I can steal that.
Yum, yum, yum.
Wait, blue, blue, blue.
Blue, blue, blue.
Blue Walker is under attack.
I'm heading over.
Do not worry.
Alright.
Nice.
Don't worry.
I go help.
I help.
Yellow.
Don't worry.
Yellow time.
I got you, Dynamo!
Oh.
I got you!
Victor!
Maybe he'll live.
I...
I wanted to be a hero.
Guys, I just...
I didn't...
They locked the hole because I got hit!
I love who did not survive.
The alt would have been very useful there.
I just wanted to save him.
I just wanted to be a hero.
That's true.
I died for the cause.
My team was able to live.
Because my team was able to get walks, guys.
I'm a hero.
If only I had alt right here.
The power of the gin.
It would have been amazing if I actually had all here,
though.
Oh, Maya.
It'll be fine for now.
Oh, no.
Are you out?
Oh!
It's okay.
Wait, he's low.
He's not actually, but I like to say that.
I like to pretend he is.
Hey, grab that.
I'm gonna steal that.
No, I can't because I don't have.
No!
So take it.
Don't be a jerk.
Don't care.
No!
Quick made it.
I got it.
Don't worry, I'll help out.
No.
Oh, yo.
I'm going again!
Oh!
Oh my god, who are you?
Hello.
Thank you.
Oh, that was close.
They took out Yamato.
Oh, please tell me.
Fix that down!
Dear me.
Oh my god, Fix that was a puppy.
I just can't look up.
I Oh my god, I just don't know how to look up
All right, but guys, come on It's not me It's not me What
guys, guys, guys, guys Because if we look at the stats here
If we weird look at the stats here guys guys guys guys guys
looking at all of this it's not it's not me me yellow wait
wait wait wait wait green green green green green green
green green green oh my god look at all these juicy sinners
green green green green green oh Fuck, there's so many
fears.
Of course, there's a rift.
Of course, there's a rift when I want to go in there.
Okay, but there's no way there's going to be...
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay.
Pull back.
I'm leading everybody to you.
I'm a friend.
Here we go.
It's fine.
I just need to tag a lot.
Tag-along!
Is there another tag-along you use?
Sure.
Oh
no!
Now!
Where is everybody?
I did it.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
It's fine.
We will- oh no!
We didn't kill them!
No!
It's fine!
It's fine.
Because that means...
No!
It's fine.
I'll do this.
Even if I don't have it.
It's okay.
It's fine.
I did it, but it's okay.
It's okay.
Oh, shit!
Mid boss!
I'm sorry!
I didn't realize we're doing mid!
Mid, mid, mid!
I got greedy!
I'm here.
I'm here to help.
I was there.
I was.
I did it.
I did.
I helped.
I was there.
No!
That couldn't mind.
Oh my gosh.
I should have went PO mode.
I should have healed him actually.
Please tell me there's another one I can potentially grip
on.
two
all right it's okay what okay
oh defend Greenwich my sinners sinner sinners sinners
sinners yum yum yum yum yum yom yum yum yum yum yum yum yum
yummy yummy nobody's here oh thank you the sinners Sinners,
sinners, sinners.
Oh.
Hi, friends.
Yummy.
Oh, my own sinners, though.
Time to break open the piggy bank and buy something.
Everything's okay, guys.
You don't have to worry.
Don't worry.
Everything is okay.
Oh, look at how much sinners I have.
Yummy.
Oh, wait, I should buy.
Shopping time.
Shopping.
I go shop now.
7k unspent.
I got too excited.
Oh my god.
Okay, duration should be tag along.
There you go.
Everything is fine.
This creates it against me.
But I'm so hungry.
Guys, I'm so hungry.
Oh, I must gamble.
Guys, I just want to gamble.
Alright, this is the only route I know.
Tunnel is time.
Tunnel, tunnel, tunnel.
I still have 1k.
You want to see me have 2k?
Ha ha ha.
But what if I have 2K, though?
Oh, surely nothing bad's gonna happen to me.
The Rejuvenator has expired.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, shit.
Our dynamo's fucked.
Get out?
It'll be fine.
And I'll afford it.
thing oh that's about this because i want to pay for
something oh oh fight fight fight we're fighting don't worry
i'm here
no i don't have it i'm sorry
What?
Headed to green!
Rimp, rimp, rimp, rimp!
RIM?
RIM, rim, rim, rim, rim, rim!
From downtown!
I'll give everybody a heal.
Gobi!
Look at
me!
I'm running!
Wait, where did everybody go?
What the fuck?
I put you left!
Rim leave too!
Runs!
Scared!
What is doing?
There is...
I'm so scared.
Okay.
I cannot buy.
Oh, my amount of spirit.
Alright.
We're good.
Oh, money.
Where's my money?
Oh, Rift here.
Rift here.
We got Rift here.
I lie in wait.
They don't know I'm waiting.
I'm here.
I lie in wait.
Surely nothing bad's gonna happen to me, right?
Surely.
Where is everybody?
Oh, I guess they're all rushing green.
Oh, what if we rush yellow?
Go in, my people!
Go!
Oh, Victor, why aren't you rushed?
Oh, you're gonna steal that.
Oh, guys.
I guess they don't know.
Does that hit him?
I don't know.
Oh, mid-boss is there.
Okay, there are doubles.
Doubles look so juicy.
what 10 seconds i'll make it i'll make it to the doubles i'm
gonna make it i'm so fast i'm gonna no my dick no my sins
i'm mad you're a man you're a man you're not fuck you i'm
stealing our own sins
Oh, shit.
Maybe I should come back.
I'm gonna help.
I help.
I do care a little.
Guys, what are we doing?
What's the plan here?
I guess I'll steal that.
That's the plan.
Guys, what's the plan here, guys?
I'm lost again.
Lost child.
Lost child's here.
Okay.
My sin...
Where's my sinners?
Are we just... I guess it's like farming period.
There's nothing to do.
Your mind and spirit will be reborn.
Alright.
Oh, Victor needs help.
Victor!
Victor, I'm coming, Victor.
Oh.
Oh, Victor does not need no help.
He's a very strong independent Frankenstein.
I should spend my money by cat.
Oh, my cat and yeah, I need 6,000.
I just need 6,000.
Come on.
There we go.
5,800.
We're so close.
Is that it?
No!
I just need 6,400.
We're so close.
There must be boxes.
Oh my god, 3,784.
There we go.
I have enough for Scourge.
So close quarters?
Alright.
Who died?
Oh, fuck!
Wait, let me help!
Guys!
They won't expect...
The flake!
And then...
Damn!
Worth it!
Absolutely worth it!
Yes!
I don't ever expect the flick that's messed up.
The surprise room.
You'll never expect a child to show up behind him.
Oh my god!
Guys, guys, not bottom score.
Room!
How is the room with the action?
Room.
dead by philip okay i swap but he's not swapping please swap
please please no get this mo kill off my team he will
remember turkey's soul greed in september no he's not you
gotta swap commas you gotta swap Yes, okay.
Okay.
We're doing it.
That pillow snipe.
That little chudlind that could.
Your family misses you, Rem.
And once you summon the Archmutter, I already forgot what I
was gonna say.
I was too busy remming it up.
I was so busy being Rem.
That Rem, that could.
Oh no, it's a bleh.
It's a bleh.
Oh my god, I hate the lengthy so much.
No!
We don't have 800!
We fucked up!
Yeah, I have 800 now.
Alright, let me buy.
It'll be me no buy, me no buy, me help.
me help me
help it's okay I have item now all right me
helping oh okay ha ha what What you gonna do?
I'm behind a wall.
Okay, let me just be a little closer.
I fucked up there.
I'm scared.
I'm gonna deny.
Okay, I pillow.
Pillow time.
Okay, I didn't hit it.
But it's a thought that counts, you know?
It's a thought that counts.
I hope he doesn't die from that.
Don't worry!
fire he's scared I get the egg I still don't really know
what the egg does everyone keeps telling me I heard the egg
is like super meanie but I don't really know what they're
gonna take me out I did everything I could it was so low I
should I should pillow the Billy.
I'm sorry, I should pillow the Billy.
Oh, it saves money over time.
I heard you have to eat it.
I don't know what that means.
From the rim that could.
Okay, I have a time.
I have friendship now.
Friendship, friendship.
It's friendship time.
Okay.
He's gonna grip me.
I can feel it.
Oh, I thought he would, I thought he would go back faster.
Oh!
That was scary.
That was a little scary.
I don't know.
Woo!
Guys, I think games are getting a little harder now.
Alright.
Guys, games are looking a little harder.
A little more rough.
He was like, people know how to play the game, boy.
Bye-bye.
Yeah, there, your souls are a little bit better than ours.
Oh, that was close.
I will sacrifice my life for this.
Um.
we in town I guess I'll die I it was it was a suicide
mission and I don't think it was worth it I I don't think I
should have left him to die I I was just like Do I save him?
I should...
I should have left him to die so I don't get farmed.
I will say it was not my fault.
I blame the guy that took me there.
Yeah.
He took me to...
He took me to die.
It might not have been worth it.
Oh, do I need to buy?
I need to buy a knockdown.
Wait, but if he has unstoppable, I can't knock him down.
He's just going to buy unstoppable.
Like, what's the point?
Unless there's, unless more than one person has knockdown
for me.
He baited me, guys.
I got baited here.
I didn't want to, how much do I need?
Okay, I almost have it.
I need to see what they have at their store.
Oh, him a little bit.
Alright.
Well, that's unlucky.
Get out of here!
It's like the duo rule!
You never leave your duo!
You die with your duo!
I can't help it!
It's literally the rule of duos!
You die with your duel, it doesn't matter if he's doing
something fucking stupid.
You die with him.
Like,
don't be a jerk.
Even if he's doing something...
Fuck this.
Oh, well.
Oh, well, then.
Well, he used...
It's fine.
He ulted it, too.
See, we both did something dumb.
Oh my god, he did it again.
He did it again.
Goodbye.
This time, I learned my lesson.
I...
I learned my lesson this time.
Not again, though.
I don't do it a second time.
I don't let him do that to me.
It's right.
What happened to ride or die?
You go guys, guys, guys.
It's like one get one ride or die per game.
One ride or die.
We get one.
Oh shit.
Secret second option.
It's ride or die with exceptions.
You get one rider die for a game.
I want to get the boxes on what the box is so bad.
I want to do it.
I'm going to do it.
No, I want the...
Okay, fine.
Fine.
I'll go this way.
Come yell him.
I'm at
yellow.
Did we not hear what we just heard?
Did we not hear come the yellow?
I listened to...
That's a no.
Not a no.
Oh my god, he's so dead.
Oh,
that's awkward.
I just got here.
That's okay.
I'm alive, though.
I wanted to grab the sinners.
I can't do anything about him by myself.
Oh.
I tried!
I'm just a little guy!
Okay, and I can roam.
Now, I go down here, guys.
Go down here, and then...
That looks so cute, so I want 40 seconds.
I'm gonna go help.
I'm gonna go... Tunnels.
Tunnels.
Tunnel, tunnel, tunnel, tunnel.
and I go help.
I go help the Moe and Creole it.
Because I am helpful.
I'm here.
It's five.
And then I threaten them, and now I leave.
And I grab their doubles.
Grab your doubles, doubles, doubles, doubles, doubles,
doubles, doubles.
Doubles, doubles, doubles, doubles, doubles.
You don't want to know?
Doubles, doubles.
I like myself.
Still boys.
Got text.
I taxed them.
I'm back.
Hello.
Greed is good.
There you go.
The greed is good.
See?
We're good.
We're fine.
Rem is okay.
Rem okay.
Not even close.
Not even scared for a second there.
Wait, did I get the doubles?
Did I even get it?
I can't even tell.
I can't even tell if I got it.
Can you do this though?
Okay.
Oh, it's just a minion?
I did it.
Breed is good.
It's like that community episode.
I'm helpful.
I am.
I am helpful.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I was trying to throw my minion so I healed myself.
Oh, yes, yay.
It's so low.
him but i'm greedy i thought i could live it i was so greedy
it's down i can't help it i'm just angry i'm just i thought
about it it was like but i could just i could just not do
that
The green is not good in the end.
It's not?
I, okay, okay, I'll solo.
Thanks, great at shuffleboard.
He's solo, I will solo if I have to.
Our green guardian has been destroyed.
Okay.
I'm about to go to green.
Wait, he's coming back to yellow.
I have to get back to yellow.
again.
Oh my god, I just cleaned yellow.
Why are you still here?
Stop!
I just cleaned it!
You can have it, you can have it, you can have it, you can
have it, you can have it, you can have it, you can have it,
you can have it.
It's okay.
I didn't even want it anyway.
You can have it.
But I should.
I'm gonna go help them.
I didn't want it.
Didn't want it at all.
I know he'll help me.
Rita's good.
Wait, I didn't get my thing.
No!
Not fair!
Oh.
I need to actually help out.
I need to actually help out in fights more.
I'm getting too greedy.
Heading to York.
Yellow walker is under attack.
No, no, no high ground.
There's people here.
Whoa!
It's not- yeah, I was stealing that Hey, that was my thing I
was trying to steal.
Okay.
I was trying to steal that.
Guys, I don't know.
Guys, I don't think I've heard, but you guys know what
character she's playing right now.
It says lash, guys.
It says lash, lash, lash.
Does anyone figure out what character she's playing?
Alright.
I do need to get into fights more.
I'm gonna help my team actually.
No clue.
We still haven't figured it out.
Okay, I need like... Oh, I don't really want to farm that
though.
I'm too weak.
I'm such a little chud.
I'm too weak for that farm.
Oh, Rift.
Alright, I'm going to Rift.
no oh i don't know if i should go to is there mo krill gonna
be okay
i might have to go back to yellow to help mo and krill
wait i know i'm staying here i'm staying here
this is the best i can do yep goodbye oh no and a great Oh
my god Guys, why did we chase this guy?
Green's gone
We did all that Down I don't even know if I dropped a lot of
souls not gonna lie
It's okay Okay, there's still...
There's a lot of...
You can be greedy again.
Big egg from Moe, though.
That's true.
I need to use Totems more, I really do.
Am I the only...
Okay.
Wait, I gotta help him.
How can I do this?
Wait, I gotta help them.
Oh my god, just...
Oh.
Look at me.
I am a child.
Please look at me.
Wait, I can buy knockdown.
Well, if he dies, he dies.
I'm buying knockdown.
He most likely will die.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That is just...
like yeah he's he's got there you go it was worth it i got
knocked down i i had a feeling you was gonna die i i saw it
wait does he want it i'll give it to him no i think we might
lose this oh we didn't hit if you think this is impressive
wait until i get going okay we gotta help him okay now help
him
all right okay I'm willing to do that please tell me I am
anybody where
are my buddies except my own friend girl Um, yeah, no, I'm
sorry, bro.
Where did the- what?
Oh, what?
Oh, my God!
Where did my team?
I swear to God, I saw someone behind me.
I'm just a little tight.
Please.
Yay!
I think he might be, oh yeah, no, nobody is alive.
Nobody is alive with us.
Oh my God, no, don't take me back into this.
Guys, this might actually, I think we might be losing.
Guys, don't worry.
I have, I have knockdowns though.
It's okay.
I got my one win.
It is my... Oh, I can buy.
I can buy.
Don't worry.
Oh, I'm so under...
Underfarm, though.
The coughing blood.
Remember me.
Please.
There's a movie.
It might be time to do the tunnels.
It might be time.
Where's my tunnel?
The one route I know.
Did I buy it?
Here's your chance to shape your destiny.
All right.
This is the one route I know.
I just go into the shop.
And then I have so much money.
I don't know if I want to be down here.
And then I go back into the shop.
Because I'm scared.
I'm scared there.
Someone's going to try and find me.
And then...
Oh, I hear what they're doing, our sinners.
They're stealing our sinners, but I'm going to just let them
because I'm just a little chud.
I hear them taking...
Oh, I hear them all taking our sinners.
And I'm going to do nothing about it.
Until now.
But now I will.
Okay.
all right this is fine I'm
sorry I did the best I could I threw a knock down but it was
too late he had a combo I'll heal him at least I don't get
It's fine anymore.
I did my best.
You're right.
Who put this child to war anyway?
Okay.
They are doing...
I don't even know we can get the rift.
Oh.
We're fine.
Guys.
Someone seems to be really, really fed right now.
Oh.
Someone.
I don't know, guys.
Golly, geez.
Rem doesn't think it's a good idea.
Rem thinks me gotta go.
Rem doesn't believe the power of friendship.
Rem doesn't think the power of friendship's gonna help out.
This yopner's been dead.
That's my duo.
Oh,
yeah.
Why am I so blurry right now?
That's right.
That's my friend.
And the salmon can still be chewed.
Well, I want to know that...
I can really...
Ooh, I'm...
I'm alive.
I don't think he's alive.
Everything's fine.
He's still just running around trying to chase him.
He's crazy, he's crazy.
Okay.
Oh, that was a little spooky, guys.
That was a little spooky, everybody.
One, two.
The lashes coming for you.
I do need some farm right now.
I need 2,400.
For whatever item I queued up.
our blue walker is under attack
there's no way don't worry i am a hero michelle beast i'm a
hero everybody
all right i should have enough now i have enough wait are we
oh we're fighting Don't worry
Okay All right It's fine, it's fine We both lost something
to that And it's okay It's fine
Ram!
Oh my god.
Alright.
I participated.
Wait, double double double.
Yeah, I won't repeat.
I'll just take their one solo.
And then I leave.
And then I tunnel.
And I take their tunnels.
Wait, do they have a calico?
Oh, God.
Let's hope the calico doesn't show up in the tunnels.
Oh, he doesn't know.
He doesn't know.
Okay.
Goodbye, sir.
I will remember you.
Goodbye.
I'm sorry.
You were not gonna live, and I have 3,000.
Yeah, I'll go to yellow.
It'll be fine, right?
But what if we get Rift?
Don't worry, I believe in those two in living.
Their HP is going down, but I believe.
Can I help?
I'm helping, I'm helping.
There you go.
Alright.
Oh shit.
Wait before they go.
Get over here, little guys.
Get over here!
Oh, goodbye.
Alright.
Now go help.
Oh, guys, live, live, live, live.
Live.
What the fuck?
Where is everybody?
Guys, here's a Billy.
what the fuck where did everybody was there not a big-ass
fight just now like
let's push Greenwich what was there not a John ass fight did
I like hallucinate that what was that did I hallucinate a
fight just now okay
I defended blue oh shit green green green oh no I'm coming
over guys please let no I'm sorry no
are they are they gonna be okay they're fine oh
they're doing it it's okay I'll stay with you.
That's right.
No!
Okay.
Good job.
Don't be a jerk.
Oh, he was so low.
He was so low.
I live those.
Who is so low, though.
It's okay.
I would chase that.
I feel like I'd get baited.
Not gonna lie.
I am just afraid of getting baited.
I'm...
It has happened too many times.
I don't trust no one.
Oh, wait, blue.
Our blue walker is under attack.
I just...
I don't have a lot of trust in me anymore.
I'm taking their team apart brick by brick.
Yes, I'm trying.
Oh my god, he has so much damage!
Oh.
I'm sorry.
I existed, though.
What the fuck?
Where is this?
Why are they in their spot?
I Please not again.
Oh my god.
Why do I just get beaten by my teeth?
I I told you I told you I that's why I don't I'm never I'm
never playing I told you this was I don't do this anymore.
I told you.
I always get baited.
I...
I'm gonna pee.
I told you.
This is why I have trust issues.
Oh my...
Snap your fight!
Oh my god, he's...
Thank god.
Please.
Where's my team?
My god, they're so...
He's so healthy!
He's no longer healthy.
He is no longer healthy.
I'm so sad.
Oh my god, it's just me and Mo!
It's...
It's just me and Moe.
Look.
I think as long as I'm not bottom...
Oh, wait.
I have zero kills.
Don't worry.
The 40-minute egg.
I...
Guys, I'm so...
I'm a supporter.
We're not meant to get kills.
We are not meant to get kills.
We are just here to assist.
We are here.
We are here to assist the team.
Guys, look.
The Moen Krill commended me.
He was like, what can we do?
What exactly Moen Krill?
What can me and Moen Krill do?
What can we do?
We did so much.
Me and Mo and Krill.
What can we do?
I'm Rem.
Doki, when people say that, you have to farm deaths, they
refer to enemies deaths.
They give a super chat, Gus.
Thank you, thank you.
percent of the time playing as rem we all know who exactly
oh yeah rem oh yeah you can see who you have who you're
playing against here thank you super chat thank you thank
you duck exactly what can i do i'm just rem i'm doing my
best as the little list of guys
Let me get my water, I'll be right back.
The fuck isn't loading in.
That took fucking forever.
Oh, okay.
Um.
Please let me swap.
Beepop, please.
Yay!
Beer.
Oh, just someone wasn't loading in.
That's really it.
It takes a while if someone's just not loading it in
general.
Oh, here we go.
This time.
Yay.
Oh, bro.
Thank you.
What can I do?
Shoot him.
I dare you to shoot him.
I dared him.
That's right.
I said do it and he did it.
Shouldn't have done it.
Shoot him.
Shoot him right now.
Shoot him right.
Oh my.
Oh my god.
No!
I, what do you mean?
I'm gonna die for it.
My gun does that much damage!
That's not on me.
That is not on me.
That was not on me.
He fucking fed.
I shot him.
I literally shot him.
what else do you want from me I shot him he baited me I told
you he fucking baited me again I told you he was like why
did you kill so I was like okay I give my life I give my
life to try and get this kill look what happened to me look
what happened to me
stop You're right, you're right.
I'll never play.
I'll never help him again.
You're so right.
You're- Rem!
Rem mad!
Rem's mad now.
Average Yamato player.
Rem angry.
I'll never help him again.
You're so right.
We all saw me shoot him.
We all saw!
What more can I do?
I shot him.
I'm just following the list.
The list said tag along second.
I'm following the build order.
Reds that.
I don't think for myself.
I just follow what it tells me to upgrade.
That's right.
You all saw me shoot!
Thank you.
I hate.
There we go.
Tag a gun.
Look, I can't do anything else.
Oh, it's like a Zarya beam.
Yeah, it shouldn't.
I swear to god it, but I can't bait it again.
Oh my god, he was...
If he didn't back off, I could have got that kill.
Angry!
Rem angry noises.
Rem!
Rem.
I should upgrade that, I should.
Rem, I'm angry.
Rem's so angry.
Rem used to be happy, child.
Rim used to be so happy.
Rim was just...
Rim had so much hope in his eyes.
So much innocence.
What happened?
Rim missed those dreams.
Rim was so happy full of innocence.
What happened to that Rim?
I saw it too!
Rim feels so cold.
It's so cold.
All right.
I saw it this time.
Man, I wish I had a lot.
I wish I had a lot.
Oh, I do.
I have a lot now.
It's okay.
Everything's fine.
I have a...
Um...
his name is zarya we're gonna just freeze him or you're
gonna sleep with him and then we kill him okay friends oh it
should have been friendship okay
oh that's awkward well he's got him right let me know when
you're i hope he's got him oh he was one He was one.
He was one.
He didn't finish the job.
Ram did everything Ram could.
Why he don't finish?
Oh, he finished job.
He finished job.
Job finished.
No longer angry.
No.
Job done.
They do lots of things.
Web,
web, web, web, web, web, web.
Web, web, web, web, web, web.
Web, web, web, ram, ram, ram.
It's not fair.
It's what I was trying to do.
Every time Alright There you go You might have I'm just I'm
just trying to Get into it Okay I look at floors now
Holy shit Alright it's 5 We're so Let's go blue.
Alright, it's five.
I have ult.
Oh, what if I just leap him, though?
Okay.
There you go.
I look down this time.
I see Benita.
Oh, but he has ult too, though.
He's gonna have ult as well.
Oh, I thought I got that.
Sometimes I just can't fight.
I hate the lame face.
That's it.
It's time.
Oh, my God.
You're...
I hope you live.
There you go.
It's fine.
Oh, whoops.
Abrams here.
Surprise.
Surprise Abrams.
Surprise Abrams coming in.
Conlist did not expect that.
Oh,
we got a guardian.
Oh my god.
The surprise Abrams coming in.
Don't even know where he came from.
Our yellow walker is under attack.
Did I not clear this already?
I like my hero.
We do.
All right, um, I would like to give credit to Abrams for
that.
Good job, Abrams.
Without him, we couldn't have done it.
I shall now defend this.
Don't be a jerk.
I was gonna say, how come I didn't get my sinners there?
Go for it!
He's so low!
Look at him run like a little bitch.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
I'm not running like a little bitch.
I was just surprised to see him.
Yeah.
All right, now I can do my tunnels.
Our green guardian has been destroyed.
Surely nobody is going to go to our guardians, well.
Oh, okay.
Our green walker is under attack.
Oh my god, green is getting fucked up right now.
All right, don't worry.
I'm coming over.
My little, those little rats heading over.
The fight won't end, right?
The moment, oh, rats getting a little, the child's getting
distracted real quick.
Oh shit, I should have stayed in blue.
I should have stayed in blue.
Why did I, oh no, our blue walker, no!
It's okay, it's okay.
Oh, it's no longer okay.
Oh, it is no longer okay.
Child's leaving, and I lost blue for that too.
I lost blue for that.
I'm coming back, I'm coming back.
Blue will not be lost.
Don't worry, don't worry, blue is still here.
Get out of here, get out of here!
That's looking right!
Oh, fuck.
That's right!
Get out of here!
My blue walker's gonna live!
That's right!
You're gonna spill out for me.
Don't worry, Daddy's got you!
Don't worry!
Daddy's gonna make sure you live a little longer!
Oh my god,
I'm back at it!
I'm back at it again!
I will protect this walker with my soul!
I don't care!
Ah!
Maybe I do care!
Oh shit.
Okay, I think my walker's dead No, my child
He kills him Please just all right.
That's fine.
That's fine My child I was I promise I'd protect you.
I'm sorry
I mean, while he's doing that, I'm gonna steal the doubles.
And I like...
Oh shit, what the fuck?
Who's in front of me?
I'm sorry, I can't see.
Alright, it's fine.
Oh, wait, they might be at...
We might be a little fucked now.
That's good, Grey Talon's missing.
I let my... It's okay, I live.
Rem lives.
Oh, I can break the wall?
Okay, that's good to know.
It's okay.
But Rem lives.
That's it.
I live.
We lived.
Oh, shit.
Come here.
If I have to.
I mean, I slept him in there, right?
Yeah.
Good job.
Good work, Grace.
Alright, I got the sleep at least.
Wait, what do I...
What?
No, I don't need knockdown.
What can I buy now?
What?
Yeah.
Guys, I would have got...
There was three of them.
What was I gonna do?
How can I protect this Mirage?
There was three of them.
I am technically new.
for him oh shit yellow you know he said we gotta go to
yellow and then i ignored him and i didn't realize that we
got we should go to yellow our yellow walker has been
defeated oh no maybe i me being there would not change
anything oh my god sorry i got too excited when
Oh, no, I blew Walker, though.
Defend Greenwich.
Okay.
Alright.
How new am I?
I started... I haven't played a year and a half ago.
And then I started playing four days ago.
So I don't know why I'm actually...
I'm still very much new to this game.
I only play Rem.
Okay.
Oh my god, is Ishii going to blue again?
Is he gonna be fine?
Aw.
Ow.
Oh, they're gonna have this.
Aw, they're gonna...
Aw, careful Rem, I know.
Hello, goodbye.
I let them have it.
We dodged it.
What the fuck is this old man doing?
Oh, there's too many things on my screen.
Oh, fine.
It's fine.
We're all here now.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, it's fine.
We're all here now.
It's okay.
We're all here with the power of friendship, which I have.
God,
God, okay.
Please tell me I have people to...
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Oh my god.
You're dead.
I'm just getting warmed up.
Hi, friends!
Alright, let's get to...
Let's go.
I'm gonna go to green.
It's not back to the kill zone!
Oh my god!
Don't worry!
Maybe you'll live!
Alright, we gotta buy it.
Alright, we gotta go back.
Oh!
Oh shit, okay there you go.
Alright, I'm back.
Oh, where am I?
What color?
Like, what's colors?
Alright, here I am.
Oh my god.
What?
I'm trying my best up.
Alright.
Okay, maybe we can make something.
happen perhaps oh apparently not
um this is five you know it's okay they can have that oh
I'll give you all right is everything okay is this every
time of course I
That's my duo!
That's him!
It's okay, I'm alive!
Funny I'm having a great expansion.
You gotta stop getting faded by it.
Ride or die.
Alright.
Wait, actually, I can steal the green.
Oh, I got a green.
Ride or die.
Yeah.
This is the perfect tab.
Nope, this is not the perfect tab.
Oh, no.
This might not be the perfect tab.
Oh, this is the perfect tab.
This is not the perfect tab.
This is the perfect tab.
There we go.
This is now.
Now I go help B-Bop.
B-Bop.
Okay, nobody's needing that anyway.
Oh my god.
Get out of here.
Oh, he killed our... Oh, I'm sorry.
I...
I should have...
I'm sorry.
Look, I... But I hit him, though.
I...
No!
Guys, I hit him.
I hit the great talent.
Maybe I should have healed him.
Maybe I should have healed the B-Bot, but I did it.
Alright.
Okay.
I gotta help.
Don't worry, don't worry, we're here.
Okay.
Oh, I'm here.
I'm here, Matt.
That guy, oh, that truck, what, looked so dangerous.
That truck looked so scary.
I gotta help the beat-pop proceeds to ignore him.
I helped.
Oh, did I not?
What did I?
Help him.
It's okay.
Let me farm though.
Alright.
It's okay.
I will help the next fight.
Next fight I help.
Alright, let me grab some.
This is the boring part when everybody's just farming.
You know what?
What am I missing?
What?
What is my next bite?
Oh, scourge.
Okay.
Actually, I'll help the Mirage.
Let's take out Kelvin.
Let's take out McGuinness.
I got you!
They do lots of things!
Those stairs so...
Look, it's a...
Zoning up!
Oh, I... Oh, there's a risk.
Oh, there's a...
There was a riff.
Guys, I...
In my defense, I didn't know there was a riff.
It's okay, we won the riff.
We won the riff.
No, riff has been won.
Let's push Broadway.
Broadway, alright.
I won the rift.
The zoning up made gay talent move away.
Oh my god.
There you go.
Grab her.
Oh, please get me closer to the team so I can heal them.
Please get me...
Go.
Okay, there you go.
Please get me closer to the team so I can heal.
I need that one last tag along.
There we go.
And now I...
Oh, that's my duo!
That's my duo!
Don't be a jerk!
.
What can I do?
If I bind to him, it's just going to be me and him.
There was no reason why I would go on the suicide mission
with him.
There was no reason.
1v6 as a boy.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
All right, here I go.
Here I go.
Oh, that's so unlucky for him.
I swear to God, if I...
Okay.
Wait, you're going to green, though.
Wait, they're going to green.
Okay.
to succeed.
Let's push Broadway.
Our green water is under attack.
Are you serious?
Oh my please, he's so low.
Where did he go?
It's fine.
I even starred him in there too!
Wait, wait, wait do you see it guys guys oh you don't see
you don't see now i can buy it let's fear sap in oh my god
you don't see oh it's so juicy though
oh i don't have any left i see great talent great talent
where's k talent
do you see though no no no do you see all Damn, I got
distracted because of the fucking talent!
We make quite the pair, don't we?
We don't.
Thank you!
If I need this.
This doesn't feel very safe.
Alright, we're good, we're fine.
We'll help the Abrams.
What more does this city need?
The Amina!
It's okay.
It's no longer.
Is there anyone?
I swear to God, I thought I had three people next to me and
I was like, you not worry, I shall.
I thought I had...
I thought I saw someone in front of me.
Where did it go?
Just a little kid.
I'm just a little kid.
Oh my god, please.
Please, I'm the only child in this lobby.
Child here.
That's it.
I'm buying, knocked out.
the reason why I'm getting fucked up but I'm still buying
knockdown it's not the reason but I'm gonna buy knockdown
just cuz I can the rejuvenator is descending oh they're
doing rejuke you need to make a stand and stop headed to
Greenwich I'm Yeah, but we could do Rift, though.
It's gonna be a 4v6.
We can take it.
I don't know.
That is a lot.
That is literally a lot.
Oh my god!
We're in my end!
Who am I in?
Alright.
Nice?
Great job guys, great job.
Look at that!
RUM!
Oh shit, what the fuck?
Over here.
Get over here.
Where's everybody going?
everyone going let's pull off ram ram ram ram ram ram ram
ram ram we
did it guys what did he do good job that's funny three times
in a row and every time he's done it and we're in a team
fight they lose because of it and they had their chase and
instead this guy wants to oh i'm so scared oh i'm gonna die
even though i'm invincible just like fucking okay all right
you know what i'm gonna kill everything they got this
annoying thing where they just group up in fours or sixes i
just started my guy all right here i go you know what you
know what's also really good with that kelvin and you know
that would win them the game but no i get some old dude
because he's very smart
My.
Hey, Rev.
I want to steal their stuffs.
Everything.
Oh,
shoot, Rev.
I'm sorry.
Rev.
Why you take me back?
Goodbye.
Why?
Okay, okay, okay, we're okay.
I hanged on by a friend.
Okay, I lived.
Oh, I don't think that...
Oh, I'm sorry, beef up, but...
are we really oh guys I don't know if that's smart oh it's
okay I'm defending the base oh my god there's still no
little rem that could I may have lived forever
But I love that you A little rem that could That's funny
coming from the glass cannon
I can see if I can sneak a peek From my genus over here
On the rem
At least I pushed back the wave enough guys
Run back, run back Run back!
Rem, run back!
What do
I buy?
Let's see.
Reach us up in one minute and 25 seconds.
We need to survive until then.
What do I sell?
Kill me?
Spell?
What do I even sell?
I don't know.
Whatever.
Surely I'm not gonna...
Enchanters?
Alright.
Oh shit, don't worry, I have booster.
I'm here.
Oh my god.
Alright.
Um...
Oh my god!
They took out Yamato!
Oh my god, what's going on?
Guys...
I didn't give me responsibilities.
Rem very scared.
Rem is very scared right now!
This does not look too good for Ram!
Ram is very scared!
Oh god!
Ram's clearing face fires!
I have tried so hard!
I have to defend it all.
Remus, don't...
Please don't die when Rem respawns!
Don't die when Rem responds, please.
Please!
Please be alive when Rem comes back!
I don't want to be alone again!
Oh, yeah, no, it's boby.
Goodbye.
The Krem had four deaths.
It's okay.
I have four deaths.
I tried.
It's okay.
Rum wasn't the issue.
Mussels.
I was not the problem.
You did it.
Yeah.
I did the first night good.
The room had muscles.
Mussels pie.
Look, your greed is on this like, at least I guys the least
I love about this game already That there's so many people
who have like entitled thoughts to themselves that they
decide to speak And it's just like insane that anyone has a
free will in this game
It's incoming that what I hear oh, I lowered it because
people were being mean
I was just like, I can barely hear him.
Ram!
Yeah!
It's okay, I get, I get Ram.
It's okay.
In the end, I get to play Ram.
Yep, yippie.
Ram, Ram, Ram, Ram, Ram.
Let me read.
Ram, Ram, Ram, Ram, Ram, Ram, Ram, Ram, Ram, Ram, in yay why
don't you use the bathroom guys i'll be right back
all right team last game i had 17 kills in in 20 minutes and
then my team decided to not be aggressive because they
wanted to sit back and farm and do nothing so i was trying
i'm feeding the skin.
So I was digging in my butt.
Let's fucking do it.
Let's fucking feed.
Let's do it.
I found a piece of gold.
There's no need to be.
What happened?
Once you complete the ritual, she will find your way.
Oh no.
Are people arguing?
I...
What happened?
I'm...
was on REM!
It's been like...
I messed up the world!
REM.
Happy.
Yay!
Okay.
It's okay, he's learning like me.
It's around with you.
What the fuck?
Why would you want to shoot a guy that looks like this?
He's crazy.
Ah, Bob!
What's up things?
Okay, that was a little awkward.
That was whoopsie.
Whoops.
Get out of here!
My leg!
Wait, let's go.
Yeah, did not!
Oh, po po po po po po!
He's so dope!
Please, I don't have to go!
He's so dope, please!
Oh, friend!
Yamato's blaze!
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God, dokey bird.
That was scary.
Okay, I got it.
Wait, I literally saw your tweet.
Okay, let's me go.
let me go over here addicted to deadlock and you're playing
rem rem that's right rem you sound like you scroll tick
tocks all the time I don't I actually don't even have to you
sound like you show YouTube shorts
I got that escalated so much I got that escalated so quickly
what the fuck no I mean I got it out of you was like easily
beat oh my god what happened that escalated so quickly is
this game
i'm out tough corona
Oh yeah, fuck it might as well.
Oh,
you so low.
If only I had...
Bro, okay, you're gonna do that.
You have to aim for that, bro.
Oh!
You have to play silver.
Fucking idiot.
Yeah, that's right.
I can use think you're hot shit just because you're playing
an aim character.
Bro, maybe you should play Rem.
Yeah, maybe.
Oh, shit.
I'm sorry.
I didn't mean that.
Where did my fucking Yamato go?
That was karma.
I just, I didn't know he would do that.
Why did he leave?
They help.
Hey, people of mid, I'm coming.
No!
He's scared.
I'll save my pillow just in case.
Don't deny.
Well, I'm reloading.
No.
Oh my god, please.
Please.
Oh my god.
Nice, nice.
Oh my god, he's one.
He's actually one.
He's round!
It works every...
time!
Get in here!
Come on!
That's right!
It's okay.
All right, maybe I shouldn't have ulted that, but I was
just... I really...
I did not care anymore.
I really... I was greedy.
I was very greedy, guys.
I was very...
All right, so they still have We're woke up, which is very
scary, which is a very, very scary ult.
It is very scary.
I know the silver ult is very, very scary.
Okay, let's fully deal with this just in case.
Please.
Alright.
There we go.
Yeah, it does hurt a lot.
Just so I can lower my cooldown.
Oh, not the wood, but...
It's okay.
I heal.
I leave after.
It's alright, I'm here.
Oh, fuck.
Whoops.
That's awkward.
No, I little...
No, I walk it.
Oh, I walk it.
Leave.
My baby.
My little baby.
It's okay.
It's time.
Oh, I thought you was there.
Whoops.
My bad.
Oh, you're so dead.
It's fine.
Yeah, slashing.
Yeah.
He's gonna turn into a werewolf.
We're so fucked though when that happens.
Unless, unless, but we don't have anything.
Wait.
Sinners time, sinners, sinners, sinners.
Our blue guardian has been defeated.
That's a no-shhh.
There you go.
Surely he's not gonna do anything about it, right?
Yeah!
Surely he's not gonna come over for me.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Do I need to buy anything?
Oh, I got buy.
Bye.
Buy, yum.
My belly.
Belly full.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Yum, yum, yum.
I like my pillow.
So I'm thinking of the super chat.
Thank you.
Kobe!
Okay, there's silver's pretty bad.
Not gonna lie.
Like, honestly, I feel bad for Inamina.
Yeah.
Like, that's the nerd.
Dermina deserves better.
Dermina actually deserves better.
I think she's playing like non-transport, well, I'm
surprised they got the walker before us.
Yeah, Rift is opening.
Guys, Rift is opening.
And I'm just a little brim.
Guys, the silver is coming.
Oh.
Ah!
Okay.
This is...
All right, because I need this.
Perhaps he'll transform.
Oh, I missed it.
Oh.
Well, this might be bad for me.
Only he sees me.
I was like, I'm so safe.
Okay, that's on me.
That's on me.
That's actually on me.
I was like, I'm so safe.
To be fair, I was left on my own, guys.
Wait, wait, wait.
We can help.
If he lives long enough, we can save him.
never mind okay oh
that's unlucky there you go it's fine where is the other guy
there he is wait what I did not get that hit I was gonna see
it just wait for the Oh my god, don't worry.
You're so healthy.
Don't be a jerk.
Oh my god, how long is this fight?
Alright.
It's okay.
That was such a long fight.
Maybe I should not have gone to the rift by myself.
I should have waited.
Just, you know.
What's the word?
if I've been a little fool.
I didn't even get a chance to go in my tunnels yet.
Tunnel tab.
Tunnel, tunnel.
Gomez has 14.
And who was it that got him those 14 kills?
Who is supporting him to be able to grab those kills?
Thank you.
Have something.
Who Who assisted?
It was so mess.
Oh, that's awkward.
No one.
Oh, I can't sleep that.
Whoops.
That's stupid of me.
I legit thought that was sleepable.
Hehehe, let's just...
It's little silly.
Hehehe.
Now I know.
I never tried sleeping a 7 ult before.
Alright, let's try knockdown, I guess.
I've never stunned someone before, so I thought...
Oh, he can't move around.
I see.
Oh, it's good to know.
The more you know.
Alright, here I go.
Tunnel tab.
Now is tunnel tab.
Tunnel, tunnel, tunnel.
Tunnel time.
Yeah, I thought that would stun.
I didn't realize it doesn't do that.
Alright, I believe in you guys.
I live in the tunnels now.
I hope nobody dies when I'm in the tunnels.
I'm so fast.
Alright.
Then the second tunnel.
And then...
Don't worry.
I'm here.
I helped.
Oh shit.
That's not good.
Maybe I should come back.
The only item I know how to pick for counter items is
knockdown.
If people in air, you buy knockdown.
That's the only thing I know.
People in sky, me use knockdown.
here I hear them hello are we killing a fellow there
everybody I'm here
oh nice Wow not nice what happened to me what happened What
happened to my un?
Our green water is under attack.
What happened to my un?
Then I got grabbed?
Oh, I stopped my un.
Okay.
Okay, that scared the shit out of me.
I was just like, what happened?
I swear to God, I had it.
Oh my God, only...
Okay.
Don't worry, we should all be okay.
Yeah, I mean, I'll take this.
No one is stopping me from getting what I want.
Oh, okay.
See, I- alright, I'll take those.
I- I didn't have it, guys.
I didn't have my knock.
I would have used it.
It was like four seconds till knockdown.
So I was like, whoops!
Alright, let me look at him for a second.
Our blue walker is under attack.
Oh no, I'm as fast as I can be.
I am.
Okay, it's fine.
Alright.
Grab that.
Shop down, shop down.
I don't know, I'm all about it.
You're looking to survive.
I should have been mid-boss.
What if we just want to keep farming?
You mean it's farming time?
Oh shit, yeah it is farming time, what the fuck?
Thank god for the silver, am I right guys?
Thank god.
Thank god we have that silver.
I don't want to be alone, I'm scared.
Ah!
I won't, I mean I guess.
I mean, I guess.
Please look at the Yamato.
Hey.
Oh.
This is how it starts.
Alright.
Was that the pop of like 87?
See, this is why I don't.
want to be alone.
This is exactly why.
I do want to, I'm going to see if I can grab more of the...
Broadway needs help.
I know you'll help me.
Ow.
See, I... You know what?
Why did I help?
I could have stolen more sinners.
Why did I even... Why did I do that?
I could have stolen that...
I would have been... I would have been over there with that
sinner right now.
if I didn't help.
That could have been mine.
That still is mine.
Thank God.
And I'll steal my own too.
Fuck my team.
Wait,
where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Alright.
I see things up.
Oh, I could.
I could right now.
I can do that right now.
Oh no.
Oh wait, there's no doubt listening listeners.
Wait, there is.
It just came back.
Mine.
All mine.
Wait, what?
All mine!
Sneaking it!
Now yummy yummy.
All right, we got help now
What the fuck?
What is going on?
You jerk All right Nice, but there's one more there's one
more
You mid boss mid boss mid boss mid boss mid boss Mid-boss.
Mid-boss.
Why am I here by myself at Mid-boss?
Ah, shit, yellow!
They won't need me, right?
I'll shoot.
Alright, I'll go help yellow.
The rejuvenator is descending.
Oh, shit.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Okay, we got it.
That's where yellow is pretty fucked up.
up guys we might have fucked up they're not going back to
yellow okay he's coming back to yellow it's all right i go
now my people need me guys you know how we have whoa
we have 9 000 souls wait okay maybe i should fix i should
spend my money Oh my god, give me a sec.
I've spent my money now.
Oh, I could buy four items.
Guys, I'm saving it for deadlock too.
My team's gonna be five.
Okay.
There you go.
See, my team's five.
Look at how healthy they are.
nice our yellow walker what oh oh no oh no my yellow walker
i didn't even realize
i see silver don't worry i'm here guys we need to use our
rejuven soon guys
Graves opens the door for our victory
Guys, let's go, let's go We have Riju I got lost I'm going
in, I don't care I don't care, I'm gonna use my Riju
Why are we still here?
What are you all still doing here?
We have Riju
Even fighting at this point Do you Do you really need RAM or
rejuves a button?
Why did we get rejuve anyway?
I almost went back into them.
What did we get rejuves anyway?
even gonna use it are we just stat farming at this point
yeah i'm
sorry abrams thank you for your sacrifice in keeping me
alive is he still looking
okay don't worry i slept the Man, if only I saved my
knockdown for that one guy up there.
Whoa!
Um...
Good luck, everybody!
I'm sorry.
I don't like being...
I'm sorry, you died for the cause you really did.
Keep it up, detective.
You know what?
Okay.
Alright.
That wall was really scary.
My hero.
If only someone else would die for me.
If only...
My god.
My hero.
Hey, there's people here.
Stay out.
Wait, maybe I can heal it.
That's me too.
Worth it!
That's right!
My hero!
You'll never be my equal.
And I still get this.
Worth it.
I like naps.
Come help!
The green is good!
Yeah!
Oh!
What makes you think?
Yeah!
Alright, what is...
Alright, I can buy my spirit sabb and scourge.
That's right.
That's what you get for chasing a child!
Chris Hatsen would want to talk to you.
Boom!
Yippee!
Oh, ah!
That's right.
Take a seat, Nina.
Togey, please.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go.
Let's go me against the world me not against the world me
not against the world me not against the world me not
against me leave me realize bad idea
all right i don't think we should do mid boss not gonna lie
me wanna leave now You don't have a chance.
Oh, she does not like me.
Yamato come get your two children.
What do I see?
Me?
Is she talking about me?
That's right!
Me!
What does she mean by that?
that every
walk is himself defend green oh I don't hide and seek what
if
I just do that it's five all right
yippee New York belongs to me I almost have no clue who he's
not hitting I think everybody's health so healthy right now
Everybody's super healthy
All right Okay, wait for me, you know what?
Oh whoops wrong one
Wrong guy Honestly, I can't see anything right now.
I legitimately don't know what's going on.
I can't see anything.
Y'all slow down.
I want to come get kills, but I'm dead.
Yeah, you slow down, everyone.
Bye.
All right.
Heal time, meal time.
Whee!
There it is.
Oh, there it is.
Boom!
Oh, he's dead.
Oh, fuck!
Oh Hmm who did piss boy?
Oh major blue ball alert.
What the fuck is this?
Arnina is yapping How do I swap to How do I oh I want to be
like I'm giving him time to like Is he giving him time to
like say more slurs?
Is that why they pause?
It's like why he paused?
You're like, we need to give him more time.
Good job.
Yeah.
Ram.
Let's hear.
Yeah.
Like the fact that he paused on the Mina Crusade.
more.
Yes!
Whoa!
Whoa, who's that over there?
Who's that over there?
The key player.
Oh, I know there, guys.
Guys, I know that person.
Guys, I know that person, guys.
I...
To be fair, their silver was had 14 deaths.
Their silver did not know how to aim.
That day five, guys.
Day five of REM.
Day fucking five of REM.
Oh my god, just that easy.
It's just that easy.
All right.
Do we play one more rem?
Or do we call it here?
One more?
One more.
What do you call it here?
Oh, shit.
Who else do you play?
What do you mean?
What does that word mean?
Who else?
Can you use that?
Can you, like, give me the definition of that?
I've never heard that sentence before.
Ooh.
else?
Huh.
Ram.
Ram, ram, ram.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, wait, wait.
Wait.
Me download mine.
I think for the last game, we got it.
We got to experience it.
For the last game, I think it's time let me download it real
quick i i think if we're we're doing a we're gonna be so
good i'm gonna be so confused i would not know who's who all
right let me download it i'm rem i like my pillow
like as i was like it's like she's revving up
All right, let's see you.
Downloading, I'm downloading.
Next,
finished.
All right, here we go.
Got it.
i've never done this before i've never next next uh next
next i'm not reading anything just like how i play deadlock
all right uh where is it mod store okay ram
okay all right here we go and I'm downloading we'll see how
this goes
all right here we go
it's downloading guys I'm going to be so confused I I'm
going to be so confused I would not know what's going to to
be going on all
right 41 please don't be what i think it is oh it has
absolutely what you think it is guys all right all right
it's down like 60 percent i'm improving you think so you
think so silent did you see me did you see me rem fair
that's silver wait actually i can look him up i don't know
how many hours this person has in this game to be uh how
many times how many days he's been playing to get out rem by
day five of rem
i guess someone was day five of rem all right launching mod
Am I launching it?
I can't tell.
Yes.
See.
That silver player could have been playing Rem.
Alright.
I mean, that guy definitely could not aim.
Holy shit.
It was so sad.
Alright.
What does it look like?
Huh?
Does it not...
Where's...
Huh?
Is it not on?
Wait, maybe I need it to be...
Maybe it's like in my lobby.
Alright.
Maybe?
I fucked up the inst...
No!
Oh, that...
How do I enable it?
Whoopsie.
Whoops.
Sorry, I forgot to enable it.
Okay, there we go.
Yeah, yeah, I forgot to, like, turn on the switch.
Yeah, I forgot about the switch, guys.
Ram, ram, ram, ram, ram, ram, ram, ram, ram.
Okay, this is going to be very difficult to play.
This is gonna be, I will not know who's who.
I will, the random sketch.
This is gonna be, this is so awkward.
I will not know who's looking on me.
This is what I see in my dreams.
If we remember to look, I see him.
Oh my god.
Oh my goodness!
Finally, the proper rem life.
Oh my god!
Did it change anything in my room?
The long room is not real.
Long room can't hurt you.
No, this is the same.
This is the same.
Rem, rem, rem.
All right.
My dreams.
My dream come true.
Wait, what is that?
Hmm.
Who do I want to play today?
Do I want to play?
Rem?
Rem.
Rem Rem Rem Rem Rem?
Rem Rem Ram Rem
Rem Rem Oh my god, what the fuck happened to you?
Rem?
Rem.
Oh my god, you get two rims?
Mom, like, you have two rims?
Solid.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You should definitely play rem if it fits you.
Rem.
What the fuck?
Okay, this rem is a little Fookie.
Rem.
Or.
So many choices to make.
Oh my god.
They're all.
When everyone is rem.
No one will be.
Perhaps.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Next.
See the super chat.
Thank you.
Orca plays a game like this.
And enjoys it somehow.
So just know that if you fail.
You're losing.
to them.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Guys, do you think I should play REM?
Really?
Alright, guys.
I'll play REM.
You already play REM.
Why don't you...
Don't talk to me or my son ever again.
Don't...
That's That's right.
Don't you dare talk to me or my son.
Oh, you should play.
No, Toki.
You should play Rem instead.
Fine, I'll play Rem.
Legs are so long.
Guys, I will not know who's who.
We're so fucked.
I don't know who's going to be who.
I don't know what old stick.
What does the REM look like?
It looks like their bigger REM was small, REM.
Like, REM.
What do you mean?
It's clearly guys, we might lose the next game.
REM makes a good marketable play.
He does!
I want to buy a REM flush.
Snowy, thank you.
Super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, the ability I will take I'm on rim so it's fine Did he
change the shop?
Thank God Ram Ram Ram Ram No Ram
How do you play Ram What do you mean you got Ram No How do
you even play Rev?
It's because...
Who's team am I even on?
No, the other person has Rev.
It's literally Rev.
Oh my god, how do I upgrade?
I don't know.
Let me find the ability point.
Okay.
Guys, I don't know how to fly.
I always fuck up the flying one.
Oh, no.
I don't know.
I forgot which button I used for self-cast.
Oh, I think it was double.
I think it was a huge rip.
Who am I fighting against?
Who is this?
The me?
Is this Philly?
I don't
know.
It's a friend.
I mean, Doki and a friend.
I swear to God, it's not a friend.
Okay.
Who is that?
It looks like a friend to me.
I don't know.
Who's who?
Thank you, thank you.
Do we get him?
Oh my god.
Did we get him?
I'm so lost.
It's all rev.
Did we get him?
For him.
Guys, this may or may not be a mistake.
It may or may not be a mistake, guys.
I can't tell yet.
This may or may not be a mistake right now.
Rem!
Oh my god.
Rem is not a mistake.
I just don't know
Alright What's wrong Doke?
You're playing Who am I Against?
Who am I Even fighting?
I don't know Oh
my god Okay
Oh My god, where am
I?
Oh, I thought that would hit them a little closer not gonna
lie
Ha ha ha I'm ripped
Okay Guys, I oh my god
It's okay
I have all two do not wear Okay, we gotta do one, one, one.
Okay.
What?
We have an idea.
Yeah!
Oh, I have an idea.
Oh, the fire!
Ah!
Yeah!
I don't know, yes.
Drifter?
What's that character?
I don't know.
What is that?
I don't think I've heard of that character before.
But I don't think I've seen...
I should have.
I didn't even see him.
I couldn't even see him.
See Ruby's around.
Who am I fighting?
Who is this?
Please, I need to know what characters I'm... I still don't
know.
I still don't know who this man is.
Oh my god, it's Abrams.
Okay, it's Abrams.
Okay, it's Abrams
Okay, it's Abrams and Venator
Oh, please he's so low
Do we kill him?
Not being able to hear the alt is a little Guys guys could
it possibly made a mistake?
Could I have made a mistake guys?
I possibly I could have possibly been a really bad idea no
never what do I even upgrade I guess this I can't I'm not
outpouring the right upgrades right now this is my second
game on I on rem wait
Okay, I thought my Yamato was with me.
I guess not.
Sorry.
I thought my REM was with me.
I guess not.
I thought my REM was with me, but fuck me, I guess.
REM left me alone.
They sure did.
How under level am I?
Oh, I'm underfed as hell right now.
Don't worry.
No.
Ram!
There you go.
I better aim than you.
I know I do.
Oh my god.
I wish I know when I'm...
Oh, I don't know how to do that correctly.
That's for sure.
I mean, I'll take those.
Get silenced!
Yeah!
Rem did do it!
I sure did!
She was...
those.
Oh my god, what do I even know for it?
Oh
my god, do this myself.
No, I fucked it up!
I'm sorry, I'm sorry I wanted to send it to me.
oh my god what's going on i'm sorry i lost this oh my god
that's a that's a rem i don't know no i know the timing but
i fucked it up i but i know it but i'm not good at it
oh please i'm trying to figure out what to level up next
I keep forgetting there's a bed in it.
I keep forgetting.
There's... I'm so...
I am not doing okay.
I am absolutely not doing okay.
Okay.
This is my second game on rem.
Oh my god, why is there a Venator right there?
Sorry, why is there a Rem right there?
Oh my god, it's...
No, not the Rema!
Oh my god.
It's too Rem!
There we go.
Okay.
Let's take the Venator.
Our green walker is under attack.
But what if I take there?
Are you?
I'll take my ones.
Our blue walker is under attack.
Is that a ram?
Is that...
Is that a trap?
Oh my
god, why is he allowed to just walk through everything?
No way.
Oh shit, that one's food.
Oh shit.
He's hungry.
Oh, don't worry dad.
Oh, that...
Wait.
Shit give me a second.
Don't worry dad.
Just
I will feed you just let me clean the wave
All right It's because I fed him late today That's why
That's why I didn't feed him before his stream because we
were both sleeping a lot today I gave him a really big
treat, but was it more so I fed him late?
It's cuz like I gave him a really big treat For him to this
morning, so I fed him a little later because I didn't want
him to be like extra bloated for food I didn't want him
Yeah, yeah, yeah I didn't want him to be like extra bloated
What are all these characters that they say they see anyway
What the fuck all right fuck me?
Oh wait, I should go over there.
Where
are we chasing?
Don't worry.
Fuck this area in particular, I guess.
Where is he?
Oh shit.
Where did he go?
Well, he has to come out of...
The Venator.
All right, well, we got him.
I...
It's okay, we got him.
Wait, there's a rift here.
Don't be a jerk.
It's okay.
There's a rift here.
Who denies it?
It's a 20 minutes.
in the game.
We're 20 minutes in the game and you're denying shit?
What is wrong with you?
I'll stay here.
Alright, here we go.
Every so yeah.
don't worry okay I thought it would I would honestly thought
it'd go a little further not gonna lie don't worry my little
pea shooter is helping no
I don't know what I'm doing I don't know about this up I
don't know what I just I thought I was trying to pick it up
myself well let's hope that's not help always I don't know
who I grabbed.
I hope my grabs.
I hope that was helpful.
I don't know who the fuck I grabbed just now.
Alright, here we go.
I grabbed someone.
I...
I think you...
I don't know.
I don't even... I was trying to fucking beat it by my I
don't know I just don't know I'm so close to all right let's
go help him out oh they're so fucked I don't even know if
helping out is the right word I could grab one all right we
both got out successfully I definitely need some farm though
guys this might be the one and only time we play with this
mod I'm actually I just actually might not have been the
smartest thing I've done
this might be one of the hardest games i've ever played i i
will oh my god it's 4 800 i i miscounted i don't even am i
i'm winning i i didn't even know no it's so hard i know i'm
very un i don't even know which one's me which one is me
which character for i don't even know if i'm underfed
Because I don't know which one is me.
I can't tell which one are these souls.
Who do these souls before belong to?
Oh, shit.
Okay, this is me.
18k.
Okay, I'm not underfed.
At least I'm not underfed right now.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Oh my god, that bridge was so scary.
I keep thinking it's the...
I keep using it as like the...
Come out and play with me!
Like the... what is it called?
The ES if I'm using the REM pillow.
So I feel like the projectile is the REM pillow.
And not the...
Not whatever fucking projectile is for this REM.
Oh.
Did I do
it?
Where's the last guy?
I'm glad I'm awake to see this.
Where did he go?
No, you bitch!
I know where you live!
You little rat.
Oh, my!
My turn!
It's my turn!
I should have landed on him, not gonna lie.
I should have just landed on this guy.
Oh, we're taking mint.
This rem on Remy.
Crap.
All right.
Oh.
There we go.
We got it.
Rem.
There was always a bigger rem out there.
True.
There's always a bigger rem.
That's cinematic.
I don't even know where to go anymore.
We have redo.
We might as well grab.
Alright, redo yellow.
I don't like doing the sinners without Rem helping me.
But my little chudlings.
Not as fun.
Her strength will be yours.
Oh shit.
Oh
no.
Sleep.
How many sleeps?
Rim on rim.
Ram
on Ram
Get him Get which one The Ram I get him Which one is that Oh
Well yeah fuck that one guy In particular
Alright Yeah!
All right, here we go.
We're good.
Don't know it.
We're fine.
We're so healthy.
Wait a minute.
Oh, shit.
I didn't realize we all left or too many reps on my screen!
I couldn't tell which was my rep and which one.
What was the enemy ram?
I...
I thought...
I saw the rims.
My rims.
I couldn't know.
Too many rims in the kitchen.
Okay, I'm gonna feed dad.
I'll be right back.
Oh, what is my pot?
What?
I don't know her name.
Why are you...
Why are you just AFK?
Holiday was fucking jerking off on jerky mates, man.
He's just doing nothing.
All right, I'm back.
I'm fucking back.
Oh my god.
That might have been a fucking mistake.
Really might.
I'm back.
Rem is back.
All right, what do I even buy at this point?
Um...
Uh...
I guess...
Reactive...
Uh...
I don't know.
Fuck it.
What did I buy?
Alright, nice.
Did I buy lightning scroll?
Yeah, I did.
I like my pillow.
I do.
No.
Goodbye.
It's okay.
All right, now I don't know if it's okay.
If we fight this.
Now I...
Now I can't be sure.
Maybe we do.
Oh my god, I don't know.
Why me?
Oh, no, what's going on?
All right, I'm good.
We won.
TGs.
All right, we're good.
Yeah, good game.
Good game.
We did it.
Oh, we did it.
The big rem tip.
Whoa, is that me?
The rem?
Oh my god!
I think that's me!
Oh my god.
The big rem performance, guys.
I think that was me.
in the game
we did it guys it's me Rimmel always wins big Rimm MVP okay
I did really well with the healing that's the most healing
I've done so far today day 5 of Rimm
yay well that was fun guys i knew you would wait look at
that i did it i will be i guys i will be turning them up oh
my god one game left i have one game left around guys yippee
and i guess i'll do i i i need to figure out how to do the
stone better i'm so bad with this honestly this one i'm bad
at it Yeah.
I think it would help alive.
I know who I'm carrying.
And I guess I'll do the other 15 wins on Rem.
I mean, on Ivy.
Yeah.
Well, it's because before half a year ago, I played seven.
I played seven half a year ago.
Or not half a year.
A year and a half ago.
I played seven.
So it's like...
So I need to do like...
I need one more win on Rem.
And then I guess...
15 wins on Ivy.
Yeah, and then I can do a rank, and then I can just
one-trick run the entire time.
Of course!
I feel like I can learn more in rank than the standard.
I can learn even faster.
I mean, four day, four, day, day five, day five, almost
unlocking rank.
Let's go.
Oh, it was a year ago.
No, the game is two years old.
Guys, isn't this game two years old now?
I'm pretty sure.
I don't like street brawl.
I think I find street bra very boring.
Yeah.
This game...
So it was a year and a half ago.
That I, like, stopped playing.
Yeah, I was in the...
I was in...
I was in Project...
What was it called before?
It was called Project Something?
Project L?
Right?
I was in the...
the closed was it closed alpha I don't know I just remember
I was in it when it was all streamers playing it because I
got invited by sure for and I didn't like it but then like I
tried I know I tried tried it out a couple more times and
none of the characters really uh oh not wrong game which one
was it called it wasn't oh that was 2xKO what game was this
what game was neon prime it had like not there wasn't a name
for this game I remember it was like unnamed at that time
Was it Neon Prime?
I just remember it was unnamed or some shit.
And then later on I got like a
Yeah, and then so I played it When it was all streamers on
it And none of the characters clicked with me And then so I
didn't So like the only character that sort of clicked with
me was 7 But even then I was like, yeah, not really But then
REM came out And then it was history
and then yeah then oh my god that shit looks terrible that
rem is on the list guys that that rem is definitely on the
list um um but yeah none of the characters are getting
clicked me until until the rem came out and then and then
after that it was remstery like that one wait i forgot i
wanted can i like look up somebody's all right how long have
they been playing silver i need oh okay is i'm looking i'm
gonna find you oh copy no absolutely not create their build
absolutely not all right let's see Oh, which one are you,
though?
Oh, there's so many jinxes in here.
But which one are you, though?
Which jinx are you?
I need a note.
Which jinx are you, though?
I want a note.
I want a note, not friends.
Wait, I know what to do.
Wait, is this like the CSGO strat where you go to they still
have it where you can like recently played with okay friends
uh recently played with i gotta know oh no they removed in
the in the ye old days you can see who you recently had wait
wait we're 36 minutes ago where is it 46 minutes oh i can't
see the wait i can't see the enemy team uh oh i can put it
the match id in the stat locker no what happened to me oh
they left okay it's just me okay what the go just go to
hidden king team page what is that
all right let's see stat locker how do i find that Oh, I
know what you're talking about.
I figured it out.
No.
Wait, matches.
Did they track?
No, they didn't track it yet.
Stat.
I'm not petty.
I need to know if they have less hours.
If they have less hours than me.
I need to know.
I am that bad.
petty i need to know i i need to know if i'm improving at a
really good rate i need to know okay is this okay it has to
be this one is that no that's not him it's this one there
you are i see you all right where are you oh my god how do i
click your profile let me stalk you let me stalk you i i
like you've been playing i like i need a note okay wait is
that true Oh my god, this guy's actual babe.
No way.
This guy's actually a little baby.
Did I bully a child?
Did I really bully a... Okay, since August... Okay, he's
been playing.
Alright, he's been playing since August 10th.
I don't know.
I don't know if this is true.
Legitimately can't... Okay, yeah, he's been playing since
August... That beat him.
Hey, hey.
He's been since august 10th though guys guys he's been going
at it since august 10th so like it doesn't matter he might
only have 24 games played versus my 88 but it doesn't matter
because he's been playing since august 10th
he's been at it Toki, that's an infinite Look, he might have
only 24 games Versus my Hey, hey, hey, look Look, okay If we
look at Okay, recent Look, if we look at games I played
Since now It's not that many Guys, if we look at that We
look at the games I played Since rank reset and it's not
that many it's not that many
anyway guys thank you all for watching today deadlock stream
i had fun playing rem where is rem where is okay i had a lot
of fun playing rem i don't know if i'll be doing more like i
don't know if deadlock streams will be very common from me
um but it's been fun learning rem not not mobas though it's
been fun learning rem as a character
it's not been fun learning mobas but i like rem anyway guys
oh guys i have fun watching as always everybody stay
hydrated posture check get up and move around get that blood
flowing stand for me head to bed because you deserve it i'll
see you guys next time everybody bye guys Bye!